et qu'aujourd'hui nous prendrons donc
tout le temps nécessaire à cette
discussion générale dans ces conditions
conformément à ce que le bureau de notre
commission avait décidé au début de
cette législature il m'a semblé
indispensable d'augmenter
significativement le temps
d'intervention des orateurs des groupes
qui sera de 5 minutes bien sûr tous les
autres députés pourront également poser
des questions pour une durée de 2
minutes je ne doute pas que cela
permettra que nos débats soient riches
et qu'ils trouvent comme toujours dans
notre commission un juste équilibre
entre la libre expression des opinions
et le respect des convictions de chacun
je rappelle que nous examinerons ce
texte en commission lundi mardi et
mercredi prochain ce calendrier permet à
la fois de ménager un temps de
préparation satisfaisant pour le dépôt
d'amendement jusqu'à donc jeudi 17h puis
pour le traitement par les services de
notre commission nous consacrerons trois
journées entières à l'examen des
articles dès le lundi matin et nous
conclurons nos travaux mercredi 1er en
début de soirée afin de laisser le temps
au dépôt des amendements en séance
publique le jeudi 2 à 17h puis la
discussion dans l'hémicycle s'étendra du
lundi 6 au vendredi 17 février
le temps du débat de parlementaire sera
donc de deux mois et j'ajoute que cette
réforme des retraites ne vient de ne
vient pas de nulle part pardon sans même
remonter à nos travaux de 2020 je veux
en effet souligner que ce PLF RSS a fait
l'objet depuis septembre d'une
concertation approfondie et renouvelée
avec les organisations syndicales et
patronales et que cette concertation
s'est accompagnée d'échanges réguliers
avec les représentants des groupes
politiques des deux assemblées chacun
donc déjà pu directement exprimer ses
positions à la première ministre comme à
ses ministres il en a d'ailleurs été
tenu compte avant même le début de nos
travaux parlementaires qui seront aussi
certainement l'occasion d'évolution
d'amendements et d'amélioration je passe
dès à présent la parole à Monsieur le
Ministre chez Olivier vous avez la
parole merci beaucoup madame la
présidente madame le rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les députés
quelques mots d'abord pour vous dire le
plaisir que j'ai à vous retrouver
aujourd'hui pour cette première étape de
discussion parlementaire autour de la
réforme des retraites et ce après
plusieurs mois de concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux les forces
politiques mais au-delà des mois de
concertation en réalité plusieurs années
de débats de débat public par
s'enflammer sur cette question des
retraites avec cette réforme nous avons
un objectif qui est de garantir cette
promesse républicaine de préservation de
maintien d'un système de retraite par
répartition qui soit pérenne et
solidaire nous sommes absolument
convaincus et je pense que c'est le cas
de beaucoup d'entre nous que la retraite
reste une par majeure du patrimoine de
ceux qui n'en n'ont pas une forme de
lait collectif qui participe pleinement
de notre pacte social c'est un lac qui
nous a été transmis par cette réforme
nous ne donnons les moyens de le passer
aux générations futures et de rendre cet
héritage encore plus juste
avant d'en venir au principal
caractéristiques de la réforme que je
vous présente aujourd'hui j'aurais
peut-être revenir d'un mot sur la
méthode d'abord pour dire cette méthode
a été celle de la concertation méthode à
laquelle je tiens que j'ai appliqué pour
chaque réforme que j'ai eu l'honneur
portée depuis 2017 avec une volonté
d'écoute de recherche d'équilibre sans
jamais me connaître les désaccords qui
sont autant d'évidence pour assurer
l'efficacité je pense la vertu du débat
et au fond je pense aussi que tout test
à faire de méthode et que nous pouvons
acter un certain nombre de différences
tout en actant aussi qu'il peut y avoir
des convergences qu'il peut y avoir même
des consensus sur un certain nombre de
sujets sans que cela emporte une
adhésion globale pour un texte ou que ça
conditionne le soutien ou l'opposition à
une réforme
cela fait donc quatre ans qu'elle sème
de retraite et au coeur du débat et ce
depuis le dernier projet de réforme et
c'est ce sont aussi plusieurs dizaines
de réunions avec les partenaires sociaux
et les forces politiques que nous avons
organisées depuis le mois d'octobre pour
passer tous les sujets en revue
aujourd'hui encore malgré les
oppositions affirmées de des
organisations syndicales maintenant un
contact pour voir comment nous pouvons
avancer sans mes estimer sans
méconnaître les désaccords autour de
sujets plus techniques
à ce titre je tiens au début de cet
examen parlementaire comme je l'ai fait
il y a quelques jours devant la presse
avec le chef du gouvernement à remercier
à la fois les organisations syndicales
les organisations d'employeur mais aussi
les groupes parlementaires qui ont
participé à une forme de tradition
dialogue social et républicains s'ils
ont tous contribué à ce dialogue parfois
épineux cela a été constructif cela a
été utile
cette méthode de dialogue et de
concertation se traduit directement dans
le texte que vous est présenté j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir autour de
certains aspects de certaines
caractéristiques du texte mais je pense
d'ores et déjà un certain nombre de
propositions qui sont directement issues
de travaux parlementaires je pense par
exemple à l'extension des
revalorisations des retraites agricoles
du précédent pour faire en sorte que les
agriculteurs exploitons nos salariés qui
souhaitent bénéficier de cette garantie
85% du SMIC pour une carrière complète
puisque faire de ce qu'ils n'ont plus
atteindre la carrière complète en
question du fait d'une déclaration de
l'incapacité ou d'inaptitude je pense
aussi à l'attribution de nouveaux droits
aux aidants qui est une question
particulièrement portée par votre
commission depuis 5 ans et cela va nous
permettre avec ce texte donner de donner
suite à cette attente que de permettre
aux aidons de valider des trimestres
contents pour la retraite je pense aussi
à la réparation d'injustice du passé
souvent rassembler sous l'appellation de
tucs les contractures les contrats les
travaux utilisés collectives cela avait
été rappelé dans une mission
conduite par les députés Christophe et
de la porte pour voir comment nous
pouvons corriger c'est ce que nous
allons faire cette finalement difficulté
cette injustice qui amène aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de d'anciens signataires
de contratus qui a demandé à faire
valoir leur droit et constater que ces
périodes n'avaient pas été prise en
compte pour le calcul de la retraite je
pense bien évidemment à l'extension de
la pension minimale au retraites actuel
demande particulièrement forte issu par
issus des groupes de la majorité du
groupe des Républicains et que nous
avons intégré dans le texte à l'occasion
de son examen Conseil d'État le texte
que je vous présente et j'en viens c'est
principal caractéristiques comporte en
tout cas vise à plusieurs objectifs
c'est d'abord une réforme qui vise à
permettre au système de retraite de
revenir à l'équilibre je ne reviens pas
ici sur les déficits du système de
retraite que le président du corps n'a
pas manqué de vous rappeler parce que
vous l'avez reçu mais une chose est
certaine quelle que soit les hypothèses
quelle que soit les conventions
comptables existantes ou inexistantes
les scénarios nos systèmes de retraite
et déficitaires pour les 25 prochaines
années au moins et c'est d'ailleurs
ainsi écrit en toutes lettres en page 11
du rapport du corps et lorsqu'on regarde
l'hypothèse centrale de ce même rapport
c'est elle sur laquelle tout le monde
sait toujours appuyé pour toutes les
réformes toutes les études
nous voyons que le déficit est d'ores et
déjà prévu à 1,8 milliards d'euros en
2023 et qu'il se creusent rapidement
pour atteindre 12 milliards quatre en
2027 13,5 en 2030 et 25 milliards en
2040 dire l'inverse ou s'enfermer dans
le déni reviendrait tout simplement à
sacrifier un système par répartition qui
protège les plus fragiles et qui
garantit les solidarités entre les
générations et dire l'inverse on ne se
soucions que du poids des dépenses par
rapport au PIB sans tenir compte de
l'évolution des recettes et donc en
ignorant pardon la dégradation du solde
c'est prendre le risque de condamner
notre système par répartition et c'est
renvoyé génération aux générations qui
viennent le poids d'une dette dont nous
aurions finalement la responsabilité
c'est finalement faire peu de cas de la
responsabilité que nous avons de faire
durer et vivre notre système de retraite
face à cette situation et à se déficit
structurel les options ne sont pas
infinies nous pouvons soit créer de
nouveaux impôts soit baisser les
pensions et pouvoir d'achat ce travail
un peu plus longtemps et c'est
évidemment ce choix de travailler un peu
plus longtemps que nous avons retenu
chacune des options peut-être débattue
mais le président de la République et sa
majorité ont toujours été clair créer de
nouveaux impôts c'est revenir sur 5 ans
de baisse et prélèvements obligatoires
qui ont donné du souffle à notre
compétitivité et donc à notre économie
au marché du travail et au pouvoir
d'achat des Français baisser les
pensions c'est évidemment risqué de
réduire le pouvoir d'achat des retraités
dans certains ont déjà des niveaux de
vie précaire et nous voulons justement
faire l'inverse et financer par cette
réforme des revalorisations de pension
enfin laisser la dette augmenter de
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
de déficit d'ici une dizaine d'années
mais pas non plus une option dans un
pays en d'État hauteur de 110% de son
PIB et en pleine augmenté des taux
obligataires aussi pour préparer
l'avenir du système de retraite pour
l'assurer ce système de retraite par
répartition nous souhaitons que celles
et ceux qui le peuvent puissent
travailler plus longtemps
là je légale sera ainsi relevé
progressivement de trois mois par an un
côté du premier septembre prochain et
donc nous serons à 63 ans et 3 mois à la
fin du quinquennat et 64 ans en 2030
nous l'assumons une revendiquons c'est
en travaillant un peu plus longtemps à
l'échelle d'une vie que nous pourrons
garantir notre système par répartition
mais aussi tenir compte de la loge de
leur logement structurel de l'espérance
de vie c'est aussi le choix qu'on fait
avant nous tous nos partenaires
européens mais aussi tous les
gouvernements en France quel que soit
leur couleur politique sans qu'aucune de
sans qu'aucun de leur successeur ne
revienne jamais sur ces réformes
c'est aussi un choix qui symbolise
l'utilité de la concertation puisque
nous avions pensé initialement reculé là
je départ 150 et que nous avons été
convaincus de la possibilité de le
reculer deux ans seulement
en accélérant la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme des Touraine puisque si nous ne
revenons pas sur les 43 années minimum
de cotisation prévue par cette réforme
vous en accélérant la mise en œuvre un
réseau d'un trimestre parent pour
atteindre la durée de cotisation de 43
ans à la fin de ce clinquennat
je précise aussi que l'âge d'annulation
de la décote reste lui à 67 ans peu
importe la durée de cotisation vous
pourrez donc partir à la retraite à taux
plein trois ans seulement après l'âge
légal au lieu de 5 aujourd'hui et cette
diminution de la période d'application
et de mise en oeuvre de la décode de 5 à
3 ans s'appliquera à l'ensemble des
modes de départ puisque par exemple pour
les catégories actives de la fonction
publique
l'âge de suppression de la décote sera
fixé trois ans après l'âge de départ
anticipé prévu en active ou en super
actif c'est un effort qui sera demandé à
tous salariés indépendant fonctionnaire
régime spéciaux et qui permettra de
financer des mesures de justice et de
progrès pour nos retraites ça m'effort
qui permet de dégager les marges de
manoeuvre pour garantir à la fois le
retour à l'équilibre en 2030 et pour
financer de nouveaux droits j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire à plusieurs
reprises mais d'une part pas à un euro
de cotisations de cotisations vieillesse
de financera autre chose que les
retraites et sur les 18 milliards
d'euros de marge de manœuvre ainsi
dégagée les deux tiers nous permettront
le retour à l'équilibre il y a un tiers
similaire d'euros financera
une nouvelle mesure
la deuxième caractéristique que je veux
souligner devant votre commission et que
cette réforme est une réforme qui est
juste et qui informe de justice nous
voulons effectivement que puissions
travailler plus longtemps mais pas pour
tout le monde et pas de la même manière
premièrement nous allons conserver
améliorer le dispositif des carrières
longues en rendant plus juste et plus
lisible et ainsi lorsque là je l'égale
de départ sera de 64 ans l'horizon 2030
il restera à 58 ans pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler très tôt avant 16
ans dans des conditions facilitées par
rapport à aujourd'hui en réduisant les
conditions exigées pour mettre en oeuvre
ce droit au départ anticipé il sera de
60 ans pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler entre 16 et 18 ans c'est un
nouveau palier que nous prenons jusqu'à
présent c'est ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler entre 16 et 18 ans étaient
traité exactement de la même manière que
ceux qui avaient commencé à travailler
entre 18 et 20 ans et enfin il sera 62
ans pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler entre 18 et 20 ans et qui
continueront donc de partir deux ans
avant l'âge légal
ce dispositif permettra aussi de mieux
prendre en compte la situation des
femmes en incluant des périodes de congé
parental dans la prise en compte de la
durée requise pour pouvoir bénéficier du
départ anticipé au titre des carrières
longues et satisfaire aux conditions
d'éligibilité en matière de durée de
cotisation il s'agit pas de mesures
anecdotique anecdotique au marginale
mais vient d'amélioration substantielle
du système souvent annoncée rarement
contre disait pas jusqu'à présent et je
dis aussi devant vous beaucoup des
paramètres qui concernent les carrières
longues que je viens d'énumérer ne sont
pas dans le texte présenté ce jour pour
une seule raison ce sont nos décisions
qui relèvent du champ réglementaire
cependant vous trouverez dans le projet
de loi de finance de finance
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
leur coûts environ 600 millions d'euros
dans le tableau d'équilibre et c'est
ainsi la traduction de cet engagement
la deuxième chose que nous voulons faire
en titre de la justice c'est de faire en
sorte que notre système permet de mieux
prendre en compte les travailleurs les
plus fragiles les victimes d'accidents
et maladies professionnelles ainsi les
personnes invalides en situation
d'inaptitude d'incapacité permanente
pourront toujours partir à 62 ans comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui à taux plein et
cela n'est pas marginal non plus puisque
cela concerne à date 100 000 personnes
par an qui partent ainsi à taux plein et
qui pourront partir un siècle plein dans
l'âge légal les victimes d'accidents du
travail ou de maladies professionnelles
pourront aussi partir plus tôt notamment
une manière beaucoup plus facile et
beaucoup plus automatiques pour ceux
ayant un taux d'incapacité supérieure à
20% dans le même temps nous maintenons
de départ à 55 ans pour les travailleurs
en situation de handicap ainsi que le
départ à 50 ans pour les travailleurs
exposés à l'amiante tel que c'est prévu
par les textes aujourd'hui et sans que
cet âge de départ soit modifiés par la
loi que je vous présente
nous demandons donc de travailler plus à
ceux qui le peuvent non seulement parce
que nous visons le plein emploi mais
aussi parce que nous pensons que le
travail est le ferment d'une lien social
et dans le même temps pour financer une
retraite plus précoce et meilleure pour
ceux qui ne le peuvent pas et qui sont
assis empêchés que nous voulons protéger
au global lorsqu'on compare le résultat
en tout cas les conséquences l'impact de
du projet de loi que je présente devant
vous à cet instant et qu'on compare les
prévisions de l'âge de départ par
rapport aux âges de départ effectif qui
n'est pas effectifs déjà supérieurs et
assez largement supérieur à 62 ans le
décalage est plutôt de six mois que de
deux ans dans la mesure où une
structurellement cet âge n'est pas
effectif tant à progresser
je veux aussi souligner que les
mécanismes que nous mettons en place par
le public auquel il s'adresse qu'il
concerne vont permettre au cinquième des
retraités qui ont les pensions les plus
basses de voir le décalage qui leur sera
demandé de départ et puis mettre moins
important plus minime que pour les
autres catégories de population puisque
presque par définition par construction
les bénéficiaires des départs anticipés
les outils des carrières longues comme
titre de l'incapacité ou l'inaptitude
sont souvent parmi les retraités les
moins bien rémunérés et les salariés qui
l'ont été le moins bien pendant leur
carrière et donc pour eux pour les 20%
de retraite les plus fragiles le
décalage effectif sera plutôt d'un
trimestre plutôt que de deux comme on le
voit dans la population générale
cette réforme ne serait pas juste en fin
si elle ne s'intéressait pas au travail
des seigneurs là aussi tout ne peut pas
être dans un texte tel que nous vous le
présenterons mais nous aurons l'occasion
au printemps d'un nouveau texte d'un
nouveau projet de loi sur les questions
de travail d'emploi qui nous permettra
d'accompagner cette réforme accompagner
l'emploi des seniors est évidemment une
condition de réussite de la réforme mais
c'est aussi une condition de réussite de
notre stratégie pour le plein emploi et
donc nous voulons faciliter les
transitions entre l'activité et la
retraite en généralisant l'accès à la
retraite progressive et en l'ouvrant à
la fonction publique mais aussi en
permettant de manière plus facile le
cumul emploi retraite tout en veillant
est-ce que stimule en plan retrait
devienne contributif pour que ceux qui
cumulent un emploi avec leur retraite
puisse ainsi bénéficier d'une
revalorisation de leur pension ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui dans le
même temps nous continuons à travailler
et c'est là l'utilité du texte que je
viens d'évoquer sur le compte épargne
dans universel sur les questions aussi
de formation et d'accès à la formation
des seniors puisque nous savons que
l'accès à la formation des salariés de
plus de 50 ans et à peu près moitié
moins important que l'accès à la
formation faut continuer les salariés de
moins de 50 ans
nous considérons aussi que les
entreprises ont un rôle à jouer pour
l'emploi des seigneurs à la fois un
changement culturel sur le regard porté
sur les seniors mais aussi en leur
donnant et en nous donnant
collectivement les moyens de mesurer
leur implication c'est la raison pour
laquelle le texte propose de créer un
index senior pour que les entreprises
prennent leur part dans le maintien et
dans l'accès d'emploi des salariés les
plus âgés et renforcer le dialogue
social dans le domaine les entreprises
qui refuseront
de respecter cette obligation de
publicité de l'index exposant à une
sanction financière et une fois cette
index construit les indicateurs les
critères feront l'objet d'un décret qui
sera lui-même soumis à une concertation
avec les partenaires sociaux une fois
cette index construit en tenant compte
des caractéristiques de bronches nous
pourrons ainsi mesurer prendre
connaissance de l'évolution du progrès
ou parfois de la dégradation de la
situation de tel ou telle entreprise
pour les entreprises depuis 300 salariés
en matière d'emploi des seniors il y
aura une négociation obligatoire sur la
gestion des emplois des parcours
professionnels appuyer sur cette index
et c'est là une réponse que nous faisons
aux demandes exprimer pendant la
concertation à la fois d'avoir une
sanction financière pour refus de
publicité de sa famille mais aussi
d'avoir comme déboucher si je puis dire
c'est obligation de négociation pour les
entreprises afin d'améliorer leur emploi
leur implication sur l'emploi des
seniors et le positionnement sur l'index
troisième caractéristique que je veux
souligner devant vous les progrès que
permettent que permet cette réforme
d'abord en matière de prévention l'usure
professionnelle et de la pénibilité
puisque nous entendons améliorer la
prise en compte de la pénibilité
notamment l'usure liée aux conditions
d'exercice de certains métiers nous
allons d'abord renforcer le compte
personnel le compte professionnel de
prévention le C2P en facilitant son
accès et la manière d'acquérir des
droits nous allons par exemple à baisser
de 120 à 100 le nombre de nuits
travaillés par an pour obtenir des
points tout comme nous allons mieux
protéger les travailleurs polyposés nous
allons aussi déplafonner ce compte pour
permettre salarié d'acquérir autant de
points qui le peuvent du fait des
conditions de travail qui sont les leurs
nous allons aussi créer une quatrième
utilisation une nouvelle utilisation
possible pour les points obtenus dans le
cas du CPF avec du CPP pardonnez-moi
avec la création d'un congé de
reconversion comme nouvelle utilisation
ce congé de reconversion permettra un
salarié à la fois de s'arrêter de
travailler d'être rémunéré et de voir
financer sa formation pour permettre
une reconversion bifurcation dans sa
carrière et ainsi pouvoir exercer pour
ceux qui le souhaitent pour ceux qui le
peuvent une deuxième activité à
l'échelle d'une carrière et ce en visant
une activité évidemment moins pénible
nous apportons aussi une deuxième
réponse en matière d'amélioration du de
la prise en compte de la pénibilité de
la prévention de l'usure et au-delà des
améliorations portées au C2P tel que je
viens de les évoquer nous voulons
traiter regarder les la question des
critères ergonomiques dont nous savons
que la mesure individuelle est
particulièrement difficile je pense au
port de charge lourdes postures pénible
ou encore aux vibrations mécaniques
autant de difficultés de mesure qui nous
avait amenés à les exclure du C2P il y a
quelques années et c'est un sujet que
nous voulons ainsi réparer
pour les travailleurs qui sont exposés
ces facteurs de pénibilité et ce dans la
continuité de la loi santé au travail
d'août 2021 loi l'initiative de votre
commission après un accord entre les
organisations syndicales et patronales
nous allons renforcer le suivi médical
de ces salariés à compter de 45 ans
avec une première visite médicale
obligatoire à 45 ans ensuite un suivi
médical beaucoup plus renforcé dans
l'intervalle et une visite médicale
obligatoire à 61 ans pourquoi 61 ans
parce que nous considérons que si un
salarié est victime d'une usure
professionnelle si les victimes de
troubles musculo-squelettiques qui
justifient d'un départ anticipé il est
important c'est justice qu'il puisse en
profiter suffisamment tôt si un salarié
consulte un médecin du travail à 63 ans
et demi à 63 ans et qu'il apprend qu'il
aurait pu partir deux ans plus tôt
malheureusement le droit est formel mais
il n'est pas réel et donc en organisant
ce suivi médical nous aurons ainsi la
meilleure des préventions nous allons
aussi demander aux branches
professionnelles de négocier des accords
de prévention de la pénibilité l'usure
concernant les métiers définis et
déterminés comme particulièrement exposé
à la pénibilité ou en tout cas au risque
de pénibilité ce fonds d'investissement
de la prévention l'usure sera dotée d'un
milliard d'euros à l'échelle du
quinquennat c'est une somme considérable
par rapport aux efforts qui sont faits
actuellement par la branche ATMP et il
viendra donc financer ces accords de
prévention et ses accordations
concernant des métiers que la branche
ATMP que les organisations de la
sécurité sociale définiront en fonction
de notre petit statistique en fonction
de l'accidentologie pour certains
métiers comme de la prévalence des
maladies professionnelles le deuxième
progrès majeur que cette expérience
permet c'est justement
de revaloriser les futurs petites
pensions pour qu'elle soit portée à
hauteur de 85% du SMIC pour une carrière
complètement cotisée c'est ainsi le
droit à une retraite minimale pour
garantir à tout ce qu'une vie de travail
sur l'assurance d'une retraite plus
digne concrètement nous allons
revaloriser le minimum de pension de 100
euros par mois à partir du 1er septembre
2023 pour atteindre une pension totale
de près de 1200 euros par mois à la fin
de cette année 2023 pour une carrière
complètement cotisée au niveau du SMIC
par ailleurs l'indexation du minimum de
pension elle a dit quelle est son du
SMIC transformant en acte un principe
vieux de 20 ans mais ce qui m'est
souvent dit que cette objective d'une
pension à 85 % du SMIC avait été posé
dans la réforme de 2003 sauf qu'elle
n'avait jamais été mise en oeuvre et
qu'aucun mécanisme n'avait permis ni sa
mise en oeuvre ni son suivi dans le
temps le fait d'indexer le minimum
contributif le minimum de pension sur le
SMIC permettra moi après moi après année
aux assurés bénéficiaires de cette
garantie de pension de bénéficier de 85
% du SMIC en fonction du montant du SMIC
le mois de la liquidation évidemment pas
en fonction du montant du SMIC en 2023
lorsque l'on regarde les effets de cette
mesure de garantie et de minimum
garantie ce sont en réalité pour tout ou
partie puisqu'il y a évidemment une
forme de progratisation en fonction de
l'état des carrières ce sont 200 000
nouveaux retraités par an soit un départ
à la retraite sur 4 qui va bénéficier
d'une revalorisation pouvant aller
jusqu'à 100 euros et parmi eux
l'essentiel des bénéficiaires 3 sur 5
sont des femmes ce qui s'explique par le
fait qu'aujourd'hui encore les femmes
sont les premières à être victime des
caries rachides des interruptions mais
aussi être victime d'une inégalité dans
les salaires versés pour des postes
identiques ce qui démontre que le chemin
de l'égalité professionnelle est encore
long
c'est aussi sont aussi les salariés des
deux premiers des cils qui vont le plus
bénéficier de cette revalorisation et ce
mécaniquement puisqu'ils ont les niveaux
de revenus et donc les niveaux de
pension les plus bas aujourd'hui comme
j'ai indiqué dans mon introduction nous
allons aussi engager cette
revalorisation pour les pensions de
retraite actuelle et donc on les
retraités actuels avec 1,8 millions de
retraités parmi les 17 millions de
retraités aujourd'hui connus qui verront
leur pension revue à la hausse dans les
mêmes dans les mêmes conditions enfin
c'est une réforme d'équité l'équité
c'est la volonté d'améliorer la
solidarité au sein des générations c'est
aussi aller au bout de la promesse fête
par notre système d'aller vers plus
d'égalité des conditions d'accès à la
retraite et à cet égard ne considérons
que la plupart des régimes spéciaux sont
devenus d'une certaine manière archaïque
à mesure que la réalité des métiers a
évolué et qu'ils sont ainsi devenus
progressivement plus injuste
nous fermerons donc les régimes spéciaux
de la RATP des industries électriques et
gazières des clercs et des employés
notaires de la Banque de France et du
conseil économique social
environnemental mais en revanche nous ne
le ferons pas en revenant sur le pacte
social et le contrat social les régimes
les régimes spéciaux seront fermés pour
les nouveaux embaucher à compter du 1er
septembre 2023 par contre les quittés
consiste à évidemment demander le même
effort à l'ensemble des assurés quel que
soit leur statut et ainsi l'ensemble des
assurés de la fonction publique comme
des régimes spéciaux seront concernés
par l'allongement de la durée d'activité
et pour ce qui concerne les régions
spéciaux dans un calendrier qui sera
défini en concertation avec les
entreprises et les branches concernées
nous allons mettre en place comme après
2010 des périodes de convergence
l'équité c'est aussi permettre aux
indépendants d'avoir les mêmes droits
que les salariés fassent au même montant
de prélèvement et nous engagerons donc
en même temps que ce texte dans la
perspective du PLFSS pour 2024 la
réforme de l'assiette sociale des
indépendants en veillant à ce que les
indépendants réalisant une carrière
complète bénéficient pleinement de la
garantie de retraite minimale dans un
tout autre reg et c'est là aussi le
fruit de la concertation nous mettons à
profit cette réforme pour solder
quelques irritons et ainsi nous vous
proposons de stopper définitivement le
processus d'unification du recouvrement
entre l'URSSAF l'agir Carco et la Caisse
des Dépôts c'est la réponse à une
demande exprimée par les partenaires
sociaux et par un certain nombre de
groupes politiques pour conclure je me
tiens à souligner combien nous sommes
persuadés avec la première ministre et
convaincu de deux points d'abord les
mesures que nous prenons permettent de
garantir et préserver dans le temps le
système par répartition auquel nous
sommes attachés et la deuxième chose
pour vous dire que dans les discussions
que nous avons menées avec les
organisations syndicales patronales les
forces politiques que ce soit au
ministère du travail ou à Matignon et
que ce soit aussi dans les échanges que
nous avons eu les longues séances de
travail que nous avons eu elle et moi
nos services respectifs nos équipes
respectives nous avons voulu faire en
sorte que les plus fragiles soient notre
préoccupation constante et que toutes
les mesures d'accompagnement que nous
mettons en oeuvre pour que cette réforme
se mette en place dans les meilleures
conditions soit au bénéfice de celles et
ceux qui sont plus fragiles par la
longueur de leur carrière par l'exigence
parfois la dureté de l'exercice de leurs
conditions de travail ou encore par
l'exposition des carrières plus
précaires ou hachées que ce soit du fait
d'inégalité salariale d'inégalité
professionnelle qui subsistent entre les
uns et les autres et particulièrement
entre les femmes et les hommes j'ai dit
ou par l'exposition à un certain nombre
de difficultés à vie et je pense là
notamment aux aidants que nous allons
pouvoir ainsi mieux accompagner c'est
avec ces convictions madame la
Présidente que je termine en vous
remerçant à toutes et tous de votre
attention et en me tenant votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions merci bien monsieur le
ministre nous allons passer donc la
parole aux orateurs mais avant je vais
passer la parole à notre rapporteur
général à Stéphanie rists pour 5 minutes
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
mini chers collègues après un débat
national dans le cadre des élections
présidentielles et législatives de 2022
après plusieurs mois de concertation
avec l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales et patronales portant sur
l'ensemble des paramètres de notre
système de retraite nous ouvrons avec
cette audition la première étape de la
réforme par le Parlement je parle
aujourd'hui de première étape car les
négociations ne s'arrêtent pas au
processus législatif elle se
poursuivront comme le gouvernement si tu
es engagé tant au sein de branches que
dans le cadre de l'élaboration des
décrets que nous souhaitons au plus près
et des réalités de chaque travailleur ce
texte porte un profond changement de
philosophie dans notre façon d'imprégler
la carrière professionnelle et la vie
des retraités la bonne santé tout au
long de la vie professionnelle à guider
les propositions pour préserver dans la
durée et la justice notre système par
répartition de nombreux débats ont déjà
eu lieu en dehors de notre enceinte et
je ne doute pas qu'il se poursuivront en
tant que rapporteur général je souhaite
que l'examen de ce texte à l'Assemblée
soit aussi approfondie et le plus
éloigné des propos des strates que
possible notre débat sera impressionné
certainement mais je le crois
indispensable pour nos concitoyens ce
débat doit d'abord s'appuyer sur le
regard que l'on peut porter sur notre
système de retraite par répartition
auxquelles nous sommes tous très sur ces
bancs au regard des données fournies par
le Conseil d'orientation des retraites 8
Français sur 10 se disent préoccupés par
l'avenir de notre système de retraite
dans son ensemble et la majorité des
Français anticipent une baisse de leur
niveau de vie quand ils seront à la
retraite pouvez-vous monsieur le
ministre revenir sur les éléments de la
réforme qui sont de nature rassurer les
Français sur la préservation de notre
système par répartition et sur le
montant des pensions qu'ils peuvent
espérer après avoir travaillé toute une
vie j'aurais ensuite quatre questions à
vous poser en premier lieu le premier le
projet de loi que vous présentez combine
deux principes fondamentaux de notre
sécurité sociale un financement par le
travail et une redistribution envers les
plus fragiles s'agissant de ce premier
point il faut être clair cette réforme
vise avant tout à éviter l'accumulation
inévitable de déficits massifs dans les
prochaines années si nous ne faisons
rien pour autant l'augmentation de la
durée des carrières et notamment de
l'emploi des seniors a également un
effet vertueux pour les finances
publiques contrairement aux deux autres
possibilités de réduction du déficit que
sont l'augmentation des prélèvements
obligatoire ou la baisse des pensions
avez-vous pu estimer monsieur le
ministre les effets de la réforme sur la
croissance potentielle de notre pays et
sur les ressources supplémentaires pour
notre protection sociale l'emploi des
seniors constitue par ailleurs un axe
majeur de cette réforme notre pays
connaissant un retard en la matière en
comparaison de nos partenaires européens
l'index des seniors et la négociation
dans les entreprises à ce sujet
constituent des éléments cruciaux tout
comme le rétablissement de la
possibilité pour les personnes qui
cumulent un emploi et une retraite
d'améliorer leurs droits disposez-vous
d'une estimation quant à la majoration
moyenne des pensions dont les assurés
concernés pourraient bénéficier à
combien de nos concitoyens cette mesure
pourraient-elles profiter à terme
s'agissant du second point la
redistribution cette réforme permet pour
la première fois à 40% de nos
concitoyens qui sont dans des situations
les plus fragiles de partir à la
retraite de manière anticipée
pourriez-vous revenir sur ce que
recouvre ses 40%. la protection de nos
concitoyens les plus fragiles également
par un renforcement inédit de la prise
en compte de la pénibilité outre la
simplification du dispositif de départ
en retraite anticipé pour les personnes
usées par le travail et l'amélioration
des droits des personnes bénéficiant
d'un compte professionnel de prévention
le projet de loi prévoit la création
d'un fond d'investissement dans la
prévention de l'usure professionnelle
spécifiquement consacré au financement
d'action de sensibilisation de
prévention de formation et de
reconversion au bénéfice des salariés
exposés aux facteurs de pénibilité
ergonomique se font sur la doter d'un
milliard d'euros sur l'ensemble de la
législature aussi pourriez-vous nous
préciser les modalités de financement de
cet effort sans précédent je vous en
remercie merci bien Madame la rapporteur
général à présent nous en arrivons avec
les orateurs de groupe et je passe tout
de suite la parole pour le groupe
Renaissance à Sylvain Maillard
5 minutes merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je tiens tout
d'abord à m'associer aux propos de la
rapporteur Stéphanie Rist pour saluer au
nom de notre groupe Renaissance le
travail effectué par les différentes
commissions de l'Assemblée les auditions
sont menées ont des indispensables pour
mieux anticiper et comprendre les enjeux
liés à la réforme des retraites
auditionnez jeudi dernier le président
du Conseil d'orientation des retraites
pierre-louisbra est revenu sur les
scénarios développés par le dernier
rapport du corps de septembre 2022 selon
lesquelles la situation financière du
système de retraite devrait se dégrader
au-delà de 2022 et ce malgré des
dépenses sous contrôle le président du
corps a même évoqué que dans trois
hypothèses sur quatre le déficit
pourrait perdurer jusqu'en 2070
alors non mes chers collègues et je
m'adresse ici au rassemblement national
la majorité son gouvernement ne font pas
leur course avec le rapport du corps
comme vous l'avez affirmé jeudi dernier
lors de l'audition
pour garantir dans le temps le
financement des pensions de retraite
soit en augmentant les impôts et taxes
nous le refusons d'autant plus que les
Français expriment très largement leur
ras-le-bol fiscal soit en baisse les
pensions nous le refusons également nous
voulons même augmenter le niveau des
petites retraites soit nous travaillons
collectivants un peu plus c'est un choix
que nous assumons oui c'est une réforme
d'effort mais aussi de protection de nos
retraites en responsabilité nous
agissons en tant que tel pour garantir
une retraite descente aux personnes les
plus modestes pour favoriser
l'employabilité des seniors pour
faciliter les reconversions et les
départs anticipés pour corriger les
effets des carrières hachées
principalement des femmes et des aidants
pour garantir enfin une pension pour les
actifs et nos enfants
à l'Assemblée nationale notre groupe
Renaissance a voulu être force de
proposition aussi dès le mois de
novembre nous avons multiplié les
auditions notamment avec les syndicats
de salariés et les organisations
patronales avec notre présidente Aurore
berger nous avons tenu à défendre des
mesures de progrès de justice sociale
comme la revalorisation des petites
retraites à 85 % du SMIC pour ceux qui
ont travaillé tout au long de leur vie
ou encore la création d'un index sur
l'emploi des seniors comme l'avait
demandé la CFDT dans les entreprises de
plus de 300 salariés avec l'obligation
de démarrer une négociation renforcée en
cas de mauvais résultats
nos amendements ont bien été prises en
compte dans ce texte de loi avec mes
collègues nous avons également souhaité
que les aidants familiaux puissent avoir
un rôle social majeur et à ce titre je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
d'avoir annoncé ce matin la création
d'une assurance vieillesse afin qu'il
puisse avoir plus de droit lors de leur
départ à la retraite merci au également
d'avoir intégré à la demande de notre
groupe davantage de mesures de justice
sociale concernant la gestion
progressive et la fin de carrière en
effet la prise en compte de la
pénibilité notamment favorisant les
reconversions professionnelles et les
départs anticipés sont essentiels pour
garantir l'équité de notre système de
retraite
aujourd'hui les salariés qui effectuent
des tâches pénibles ne sont pas
forcément ceux qui bénéficient d'un
régime spécial garantissant un âge avant
un départ avant l'âge légal demain si
nous prenons pas de mesure de mesure par
non le déficit cumulé du système de
retraite pourrait être atteindre 500
milliards d'euros en 2047 500 milliards
d'euros en plus pour les Français
d'ailleurs lorsqu'on compare notre pays
à nos voisins européens sur l'âge du
départ en retraite on se rend compte que
notre réforme reste un bon compromis
comparé par exemple à l'Allemagne ou
l'âge légal et de 65 ans et 8 mois 67
ans 2031 au Pays-Bas c'est 66 ans et 7
mois en Espagne 65 ans au Danemark
patrie de la social-démocratie c'est 67
ans je m'arrêterai là chacun en tirera
les conclusions qui s'imposent
monsieur le ministre à l'issue du
conseil des ministres de ce matin vous
avez fait un certain nombre d'annonces
aussi je souhaiterais avoir des
précisions sur trois points premier
point suite à des négociations
renforcées quelles conséquence
envisagez-vous pour les entreprises qui
ont de mauvais résultats à l'index sur
l'emploi des seniors
deuxième point concernant la pénibilité
du travail quels sont les nouveaux
critères que votre gouvernement envisage
de prendre en compte enfin troisième
point comme vous le savez nous sommes
attachés à l'idée de favoriser le rachat
plus souple de trimestres de cotisations
quel est votre position sur ces mesures
défendues par le groupe Renaissance je
vous en remercie merci bien monsieur le
député Monsieur Thomas ménager pour le
rassemblement national merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre vous me
permettrez de commencer cette
intervention par une citation cette
volonté de reculer l'âge de la retraite
et doublement injuste car elle fera
porter l'effort par des générations déjà
touchées par la précarité et un chômage
historique cela peut être vous
surprendre monsieur munissent mais nous
sommes d'accord car en effet ces propos
sont les vôtres lors du combat que vous
avez mené avec force contre les réformes
vertes en 2010 pourtant 13 ans après
vous êtes devenus l'artisan d'une
réforme encore plus injuste qui sera à
l'origine des souffrances pour nos
concitoyens particulièrement ceux qui
travaillent tôt
on écoute monsieur le député poursuivez
Macron étaient celles de l'abandon des
Français le Mozart de la finance nous
promettait une symphonie de réussite
économique il se révèle en réalité comme
le chef d'orchestre du déclin
ubérisation de notre économie avec des
gains de providictivité nulles
politiques familiale et nataliste
inexistante absence de vision en matière
de l'industrialisation et de
souveraineté la pire balance commerciale
de notre histoire c'est vous la pénurie
des médicaments c'est VOUS AUSSI mort de
notre industrie nucléaire la fermeture
de Fessenheim c'est vous la soumission
marché européen d'électricité c'est
encore vous en bref comme dirait une de
vos rallier vous avez cramé la caisse et
vous demandez aujourd'hui aux Français
de raquer avec cette réforme qui ne vise
finalement qu'à générer des recettes
supplémentaires pour combler les 600
milliards de dettes créées par Emmanuel
Macron alors que le président du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites a admis ici
la semaine dernière que je cite les
dépenses de retraite sont relativement
maîtrisées vous jouez sur les peurs des
Français pour tenter de justifier
l'urgence d'une telle réforme
mais comme d'habitude vos comptes ne
sont pas bons demandez aux Français de
travailler plus longtemps c'est
provoquer mécaniquement des transferts
de charges du système de retraite vers
l'assurance ou l'insistance tel que le
chômage la maladie l'invalidité ou
encore le RSA et vos présentations de
les mentions pas du tout donc une
question toute simple monsieur le
ministre s'agit-il d'un mensonge ou d'un
oubli ce sont pourtant les données qui
sont très documentées le rapport de la
Cour des comptes de 2021 chiffre la
réforme verte à plus de 3 milliards de
dépenses sociales supplémentaires le
corps lui-même page 132 puisque vous
citez les pages prévoit une explosion
des dépenses sociales pour votre réforme
près de 4 milliards il y a même des
économistes en Rister d'ignac ont cité
qu'un qui chiffre votre réforme à 11
milliards de dépenses sociales nouvelles
votre réforme va donc créer beaucoup de
souffrance pour au final je pense un
gars très marginal aussi pouvez-vous
nous présenter un bilan réel un bilan
macroéconomique sincère de cette réforme
toutefois au-delà des considérations
budgétaires votre réforme est surtout
celle de l'injustice sociale injustile
social pour les seniors bien entendu la
France a le pire taux d'activité des
seigneurs de l'Union europ des pires
vous le savez pertinemment beaucoup
d'entre eux n'arriveront pas à
travailler jusqu'à 64 ans et donc pas de
carrière pleine et donc pas de 1200
euros pour tous contrairement à ce que
vous voulez c'est croire la mise en
place d'un index montre votre
méconnaissance des enjeux puisque cela
ne réglera clairement rien injustice
entre les plus riches et les plus
pauvres votre réforme est véritablement
sacrificielle c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est l'aveu d'une des députés de votre
majorité puisqu'elle va frapper
majoritairement les plus modestes ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt avec
votre réforme c'est eux qui devront
travailler plus vous répéter à qui veut
l'entendre que l'espérance de vie
augmente et l'Insee pourtant note qui
existe une différence d'espérance de vie
de 13 ans entre les plus modestes et les
plus aisés et ce sont les plus modestes
qui devront travailler plus longtemps
les retraités monsieur le ministre ne
sont pas des lignes d'un tableur Excel à
Bercy l'âge de la retraite relève en
réalité d'un choix de société les
retraités contribue à la vie de la
société par leurs activités dans nos
communes notamment rurales je le sais
ils participent à la vie associative ou
municipale 55% des maires ont
aujourd'hui plus de 60 ans combien la
crèche et d'heures supplémentaires pour
les assistantes maternelles faudra-t-il
si nous retraités garde pendant deux ans
de moins à minima leurs petits-enfants
combien de cantines faudra-t-il en plus
si nous retraités n'accueille pas pour
le déjeuner leur petit enfant c'est ça
la réalité si une réforme doit s'opérer
elle ne peut être réalisée en moins de 2
mois alors que d'autres pays comme la
Suède qu'il regrette aujourd'hui ont mis
près de 10 ans à en débattre et le
regret pourtant le pays du Front
populaire mérite mieux que cette réforme
décidait unilatéralement dans un PLFSS
rectificatif avec en ligne de mire le
47,1 et après le 49-3 la question du
référendum que vous avez balayé d'une
main avec mépris doit aussi se poser
beaucoup de mépris beaucoup d'arrogance
pour imposer une réforme qui agace
jusque dans vos rangs vous n'avez
décidément rien retenu je le pense du
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
donc face à vous face aux républicains
qui sont vendus en partie face à la
gauche qui a voté l'acte premier de la
réforme Touraine l'acte premier de cette
réforme avec la réforme Touraine si les
socialistes je vous le confirme les
Français peuvent compter sur le
rassemblement national sur ces élus pour
combattre ce projet de classe sociale je
vous remercie très bien je passe la
parole à Adrien Clouet pour la France
insoumise nups pour 5 minutes
présidente
vous avez déjà perdu dans les têtes en
effet 80 % du pays à minima et contre
votre réforme un petit peu comme vous
monsieur le ministre avant du coup de
devenir ministre et retourner votre
veste sur ce plan aujourd'hui vous êtes
minoritaire car tout le monde a compris
qu'à 64 ans c'est dangereux de penser du
métal à bout de bras ou porter des
cartons en entrepôt vous êtes
minoritaire car tout le monde a compris
qu'une infirmière ou un chauffeur de bus
à 65 ans se met en danger
personnellement ainsi que les usagers ou
les usagers vous êtes minoritaire car
tout le monde a compris que vous allez
transformer des retraités en chômeur ou
en allocataire 230
000 d'après les estimations de l'adresse
donc vos propres services ministériels
qui simulent les effets de la réforme
vous êtes minoritaire car tout le monde
a compris que vous allez taper dans la
caisse votre nouvelle lubie c'est
maintenant de prélever les fonds dédiés
aux accidents du travail alors que
ceux-ci en conséquence de votre réforme
vont se multiplier vous êtes minoritaire
car tout le monde a compris que vous
avez volontairement dilapidé l'argent
des cotisations retraite en les
supprimant sur les primes que vous avez
multiplier depuis 5 ans les exonérations
que vous avez elle-même multiplié vous
êtes minoritaire car tout le monde a
compris que les contes de la sécurité
sociale et de la retraite en particulier
ne sont pas menacés vous êtes
minoritaire car tout le monde est en
capacité aujourd'hui de se réunir de
prendre le rapport du corps d'examiner
graphique après graphique pour
comprendre de quoi il en ressort et voir
que la situation catastrophique que vous
dépliez ne correspond pas à la réalité
vous êtes minoritaire car tout le monde
a compris que dans un pays immensément
riche il n'est pas normal qu'on puisse
subsister sous le seuil de pauvreté
après une vie de travail vous êtes
minoritaire car plus personne ne vous
croit l'exemple des 1200 euros est
flagrant vous nous avez annoncé qu'on
aurait des retraites minimum à 1200
euros puis 1200 euros brut puis
finalement plus pour tout le monde à ce
rythme ce sera le RSA au mois de
décembre et c'est parce que vous êtes
minoritaire que la mobilisation est
immense dans le pays 2 millions de
personnes je dis à l'appel des syndicats
150.000 samedi à l'appel des
organisations de jeunesse qui défendent
toutes et tous la retraite avant
l'arthrite mais une question revient
assez souvent dans les manifestations
les réunions publiques pourquoi font-ils
cela et bien tout simplement parce que
vous n'aimez pas le travail des
retraités vous n'aimez pas le travail
lorsqu'il est libre vous préférez des
seniors au chômage au RSA plutôt que des
seniors qui s'engagent auprès des
associations auprès de leurs voisins
auprès de leurs proches car oui c'est
cela un retraité ou une retraité
aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un qui exerce
des activités de manière libre et qui
permet d'exercer un petit peu le droit
au bonheur au quotidien pour ses proches
car pas une cérémonie de nouvelle année
dans ma circonscription j'imagine dans
les vôtres également sans que l'on
vienne nous voir inquiets pour rappeler
que les anciens font tourner nos
communes je pense ici à plusieurs
témoignages récoltés depuis quelques
semaines par exemple dans la commune de
Beauzelle Isabelle ambassadrice culturel
de la ville qui animent les cours de
théâtre depuis 1989 grâce à son droit à
la retraite je pense à Jean-Pierre aux
souvenirs français à Toulouse qui
organise chaque jour des interventions
en milieu scolaire ou des cérémonies
mémorielles je pense au bénévole du
Téléthon dans de nombreux départements
qui ne ramasseraient rien sans les
jeunes retraités qui s'y engagent je
pense aux différents praticiens
pratiquants de sport ou joueur de
pétanque des minimes qui seraiente s'il
aurait traité ne pouvait pas gérer la
caisse de l'Association Sportive je
pense au retraités d'EDF qui viennent
donner un coup de main lorsque on a un
problème électrique à la maison avec son
compteur ou qu'on a une panne je pense à
la moitié des associations de ce pays
qui sont présidées par des retraités
ainsi repousser l'âge de départ à la
retraite c'est combattre tout ce que
font les retraités ces combattre ces
personnes qui tiennent des cafés des
bibliothèques donne des concerts font du
soutien scolaire entretiennent des
espaces verts donnent des cours de
bricolage assurent de l'aide alimentaire
accompagnées jeunes pour le permis mais
tout cela ne vous intéresse pas beaucoup
car si cela de la valeur ça ne génère
pas de profits privés bref monsieur le
ministre en conclusion pour reprendre
des propos que vous auriez pu tenir
vous-même avant votre nomination la
retraite à 60 ans on s'est battu pour la
gagner et on se battra pour la garder
très bien la parole est à Monsieur
Thibaut Bazin pour les républicains
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous venez nous présenter votre
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale rectificative pour 2023
qui se décline en 84 pages reçus à 12h40
ce jour un PDFs c'est toujours
l'occasion au regard du concept de
regarder les moyens à louer notre
système de protection sociale alors
celui-ci est en danger sa pérennité est
menacée pour plusieurs raisons notre
système de santé est en tension
l'assurance maladie au travers des
négociations conventionnelles en cours
peine à mieux valoriser le travail de
nos soignants la natalité a atteint le
niveau le plus bas depuis la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale après plusieurs
rabots successifs ces 10 dernières
années ce n'est qu'un démographique est
alarmant les déficits budgétaires
s'accumulent et les prévisions sont très
inquiétantes pour les retraites avec un
déficit qui devrait atteindre 14
milliards en 2030 la nouvelle génération
perd confiance en l'avenir de notre
système et peut-être même dans la nation
les jeunes doutes de la transmission
c'est un défi majeur l'inflation
actuelle menace le pouvoir d'achat
préoccupation principale de nos
concitoyens en ce moment c'est la raison
pour laquelle il nous faut nous adapter
à ces réalités enfin nos compatriotes
attendent légitimement davantage de
justice que le travail soit mieux
valorisé que les allocations sociales
que les fraudes soient mieux combattus
ce contexte est en rappelé vous proposer
de rectifier le budget de la Sécurité
sociale pour 2023 en le résumant à la
seule branche vieillesse c'est dommage
bien sûr la population vieillit et le
rapport entre le nombre de retraités le
nombre de cotisants évolue des
favorablement il nous faut préserver ce
pouvoir d'achat non seulement des actifs
mais aussi des retraités c'est pourquoi
il faut prendre des mesures les plus
justes possibles pour éviter une baisse
du niveau de vie des retraités
d'aujourd'hui comme de demain sans
altérer le niveau de vie des actifs
c'est pourquoi nous pensons que des
mesures doivent être prises pour éviter
l'augmentation des cotisations et la
diminution des pensions mais notre
système de retraite par la dispersion
qu'il nous faut préserver dépend avant
tout du renouvellement des générations
Orient ou presque à part la prise en
compte des congés parentaux pour les
carrières longues n'est prévu pour
restaurer une politique familiale
ambitieuse l'équilibre durable passe
pourtant par rien investissement dans la
branche famille dans quelle mesure
êtes-vous prêt à rétablir un véritable
soutien aux familles de classe moyenne
qui travaillent vous semblez renvoyer à
plus tard la mise en oeuvre de
l'universalité des droits conjugaux et
familiaux alors qu'il n'y a pas moins de
11 systèmes différentes pensions de
réversion que les fonctionnaires n'ont
pas les mêmes droits familiaux que les
salariés du privé pour que la réforme
soit écrit virée il ne faut pas renvoyer
à plus tard ces mesures attendues et ce
reports n'ont que rien de bon quand on
constate votre report depuis des années
d'une loi sur le grand âge même si
l'attribution à l'article 12 de nouveau
droit pour les aidants est un bon pas
quand on réforme dans un tel contexte il
faut veiller aussi à l'acceptabilité
sociale or votre projet impact ceux qui
devrait partir dès cette année à partir
au 1er septembre il serait judicieux que
cette réforme ne se met en place qu'à
partir du 1er janvier prochain
permettant de la visibilité à ceux qui
vont partir en retraite et que les
systèmes d'information soit aussi prêts
pour garantir une fiabilité des calculs
des pensions alors qu'on constate déjà
actuellement un nombre trop important
d'erreurs dans la liquidation bien
souvent au détriment de l'assuré il faut
également être juste envers ceux qui ont
commencé tôt qu'ils puissent partir plus
tôt s'il le souhaite or avec cette
réforme ce qui ont commencé à 20 ans
après 1971 sans interruption vont devoir
cotiser 44 années contre 43 pour ceux
qui ont commencé à 21
nous porterons des amendements pour
corriger cette injustice concernant les
retraités actuels aux carrières
complètes qui ont travaillé toute leur
vie mais bénéficient de petites pensions
nous vous avons demandé de les
revaloriser pour y répondre vous avez
annoncé à l'article 10 une
revalorisation autour de 85 % du SMIC
net mais vous avez précisé page 43 que
pour en bénéficier il faudrait avoir
cotisé à je cite un revenu équivalent au
SMIC or bon nombre de ceci n'ont pas
toujours eu de tels revenus vous le
savez bien avec l'assiette de cotisation
ce qui explique d'ailleurs leur petite
pension actuelle alors qu'ils n'ont pas
bien souvent pas compté leurs heures je
pense notamment aux indépendants le
compte n'est donc pas à ce stade il faut
corriger cela sinon beaucoup seront
légitimement déçus va réaliser le
travail d'hier d'aujourd'hui et de
demain voilà un objectif qui doit
accompagner le souci d'équilibre
budgétaire mais surtout le souci que les
efforts soient justes et pour tous nous
souhaitons ainsi un renforcement de la
lutte contre les fraudes notamment aux
pensions versées à l'étranger il n'y a
rien dans le texte c'est une question de
justice sociale il faudra aussi
s'assurer que les cotisations pour les
retraités Ayo retraite c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons exigé
l'annulation du transfert de
recouvrement des cotisations à gérarcho
que la majorité avait refusé l'automne
dernier en votant contre nos amendements
l'article 3 y répond en faisant en
marche arrière et c'est très bien ainsi
tout comme la prise en compte des tucs
article 11 nous croyons enfin la liberté
celle de pouvoir continuer à travailler
celle d'organiser sa fin de carrière de
manière plus souple vous prévoyez des
assouplissements mais cela semble
insuffisant nous portons des amendements
pourra vraiment améliorer la retraite
progressive et cumule emploi retraite
pour conclure je forme le vœu que nos
travaux en commission et en séance
permettent de corriger et compléter ce
pénétrer actif afin d'assurer l'avenir
de notre système de protection sociale
de le rendre plus juste par la
valorisation du travail de garantir son
équilibre et surtout de restaurer en lui
la confiance des nouvelles générations
il en va de la cohésion nationale il en
va aussi de la cohésion
intergénérationnelle
merci bien la parole est à Philippe
Vigier pour le groupe démocrate modem et
indépendant
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en
démarrant cette discussion commission
cet après-midi je voudrais dire au
ministre d'abord que nous partageons
avec lui
cette conviction très forte que
d'ailleurs Thibault Bazin le disait à
l'instant le socle républicain
il doit être conforté et les retraites
c'est un élément très fort de ces
centres républicain qui ne peignait ici
en dehors de ceux qui nous expliquent
avec un peu d'arrogance que il y a pas
de fragilité sur ces systèmes de
retraite qui peut nous dire ici que le
risque démographique il n'est pas devant
nous qui peut nous dire ici qu'il a
jamais renié la parole présidentielle
lorsque on nous avait expliqué que tout
le monde avait la retraite à 60 ans et
qui a pris une loi Touraine est arrivée
mettant à sac naturellement ce qui avait
été un moment annoncé en disant
gratuitement on va tout faire donc nous
nous sommes convaincus monsieur ministre
et vous le savez je tiens à vous
remercier au nom du groupe et
personnellement d'abord de votre
capacité d'écoute
du temps que vous avez donné aussi pour
travailler les uns et les autres et je
pense qu'un tel débat mérite mes chers
collègues et tout le respect que l'on se
doit les uns les autres parce que nous
avons des convictions différentes c'est
que on puisse le faire avec une certaine
sérénité parce que les Français ils
attendent cela ils attendent de ce
projet contre projet ils attendent aussi
que la confiance soit là parce que
Adrien cloué parlait des cérémonies du
jeu moi les jeunes viennent me voir me
disant ce qui nous ont une retraite donc
c'est à nous à faire cette pédagogie à
nous expliquer ce que nous sommes en
train de faire c'est naturellement pour
les générations qui viennent et qu'on ne
peut pas dire uniquement gratuitement
bien voilà tout va très bien on ne
touche rien vous savez c'est le fameux
film du guépard que tout change pour que
rien ne change si rien ne change tout
changera mais tout changera aussi avec
les conséquences que nous connaissons
notamment une érosion des petites
retraites parce que vous savez quand on
parle de sujets des petites retraites je
vois que les larmes de crocodile
arrivent au moment où pourtant il y a
encore des gens qui est là où nous
parlons 850 euros 900 euros de retraite
et pour cela personne ne disait vous
alors bon monsieur le ministre je
souhaiterais simplement que l'on puisse
préciser quelques points par rapport au
projet tel que il a été pour le moment
transmis à l'issue du conseil des
ministres naturellement le groupe que
nous sommes offrant des propositions de
manière à ce que l'on puisse encore
enrichir ce texte pour essayer d'aboutir
dans les meilleures conditions sur le
taux d'emploi des seniors ça a été dit
tout dans des seniors je rappelle
d'ailleurs qu'il y a une très belle
étude qui est sortie par le service
économistes il y a quelques jours et qui
rappelait que si on avait simplement
100000 seniors en plus employé chaque
année c'était un milliard de recettes
qui tombait dans les caisses de l'État
ayant particulier pour les retraites
donc vous avez indiqué qu'un salon
d'index allait être mis en place pour
les grandes entreprises les petites
entreprises
notamment jusqu'à 300 salariés quelle
est la feuille de route que vous êtes
donnée quel est l'objectif sous 4 ou 5
ans en matière de taux d'emploi des
seniors comment y arriver elle est
ouvert les pénalités financières et
qu'allez-vous faire pour les petites
entreprises parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'elles sont très nombreuses et pour
lesquelles il n'y a pas d'index qui soit
pour le moment programmé
la seconde question concerne
naturellement les cahiers hachées ou
c'est que c'est un sujet dont on parle
souvent
à l'intérieur ce qui vient de dire qui
vaut Bazin sur les aidants je crois que
c'est une véritable avancée parce qu'il
y a des hommes et des femmes qui
prennent des disponibilités pour
accompagner un être cher qu'en est-il de
ceux qui malheureusement confronté à la
maladie dans leur vie professionnelle à
plusieurs reprises va leur carrière
extrêmement perturbées ou d'autres qui
malheureusement subissent des ruptures
professionnelles qui ne sont pas de leur
sort donc des ruptures professionnelles
suivies est-ce que oui non sur cette
piste on pourra aller plus loin pour
faire en sorte que celles et ceux qui
sont frappés par ces cari arrachées dans
une retraite à taux plein qui a 67 ans
concernant la pénibilité notamment le
salut le fait que le compte perso
personnel de prévention soit améliorée
est-ce que le déplafonnement de points
permettra à l'issue peut-être d'un
dialogue avec les partenaires sociaux
quel est le chemin où vous souhaitez
emprunter permettra peut-être une
de faire bénéficier ces salariés de
trimestres complémentaires qui leur
donnerait la possibilité justement de
partir plus tôt la quatrième question
concerne naturellement toutes les
petites retraites souligne ce que j'ai
dit au début de mon propos de cette
augmentation sans précédent à 85 % du
SMIC vous avez rassuré sur le fait que
cette augmentation suivrait le coup du
SMIC pourriez-vous nous préciser quelle
est parmi les publics concernés
commenceraient partie style entre ceux
qui ont des carrières à taux plein et
ceux qui ont des cailleurs extrêmement
fragilisés et quelle est la
proportionnalité que vous allez
installer de manière à ce que chacun
puisse se retrouver de façon positive ma
cinquième question c'est sur les
cumulampereur retraite là encore cette
question était abordée à la fois par
Stéphane iris et Thibault Bazin de
savoir quels sont les nouveaux
dispositifs que vous allez mettre en
place ça fait partie à nos yeux du temps
choisi et dans l'aide du responsabilité
certains veulent travailler plus
longtemps qu'on reste la possibilité
mais vous savez qu'il y a un centre de
freins qui existent à l'heure actuelle
et le dernier mot c'est sur les rachats
de trimestres rachat de trimestre parce
que naturellement pour les jeunes qui
démarrent le Space de 44 ans est un
spectre qui est pas leur paraît
extrêmement éloigné dans quelle mesure
pourront-ils racheter des trimestres
dans les conditions plus sécurisées que
maintenant merci
pile poil merci bien monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Arthur de la
porte pour le groupe socialiste et
apparenté nupes merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues finalement la
concertation que vous avez promise
apparaît pour ce qu'elle est
simulacre destiné à faire croire que
vous avez d'autres priorités que celle
que vous souffle le Medef et à mépris
pour les propositions faites par les
autres partenaires sociaux que vous
recevez finalement sans les écouter ni
les entendre par ailleurs cette volonté
de reculer l'âge de la retraite et
doublement injuste ces mots et je
préfère citer les grands auteurs dans
leur intégralité même si certains les
ont évoqué monsieur le ministre voulait
connaissez bien puisqu'ils sont ceux
d'un homme de gauche d'un élu qui ne
négociait pas avec la droite dur d'un
ancien socialiste qui s'identifié au
principe et aux valeurs de la justice
sociale
injuste vous l'aviez dit à 13 ans
comment ne pas faire le parallèle
aujourd'hui votre effort elle est
injuste injuste pour les carrières donc
injuste pour les femmes injustes pour
les seniors injuste pour les métiers
pénible injuste pour les carrières âgées
injuste pour les jeunes injuste pour les
plus précaires injuste pour les
accidentés de la vie injuste pour ces
femmes d'abord toutes ces femmes d'abord
les femmes et tous ces hommes les moins
diplômés au plus bas salaire qui devront
travailler plus longtemps c'est la
réalité et je vous entends protester
chers collègues mais c'est la réalité
pour assouvir votre politique libérale
injuste pour ces françaises et ses
français ces essentiels ce que nous
applaudissions tous il y a peu dont les
corps sont déjà abîmés mais que vous
allez abîmer encore et encore injuste
pour le secteur de la dépendance que
vous allez saturer un peu plus injuste
pour les cas faut aussi parlons-en que
vous allez inonder de nouveaux dossiers
RSA après avoir réduit les droits à
l'assurance chômage
quant aujourd'hui on est peu qualifié
quand on vit dans une région en
difficulté industrielle quand on est
soi-même en difficulté quand on a une
carrière facturée bon courage déjà pour
arriver à 62 ans alors si vous ne vous
écoutez pas monsieur le ministre Olivier
du socle il y a 13 ans écoutez au moins
le président de la République il y a 3
ans qui prononçait ces derniers mots et
renoncer à votre réforme parce que vous
n'avez de cesse de répéter que votre
réforme rétablit un maximum d'égalité
vous l'avez encore dit il y a quelques
instants mais cette réforme tout le
monde le constate elle est destructrice
elle est vide de justice on le disait
ils sont quasiment aussi vite de justice
que l'été les membres du groupe horizon
puisqu'il n'y aura même pas d'orateur
d'un des membres majeurs de votre
majorité pour soutenir ce texte c'est
malheureux mais nous démonrerons nous ce
vide ce déni de justice dans les débats
à venir les prues fragiles votre
préoccupation constante disiez vous tout
à l'heure seront les plus et vos mots
creux ne suffiront pas à faire par avant
à la réalité subie dans faire parler
français la tentative d'hypnose à
laquelle nous vous avons assisté tout à
l'heure n'a pas fonctionné et je vous
rassure votre discours est creux mais
permettre moi aussi de regretter
l'instrumentalisation de certains sujets
comme celui des tucs pas besoin de
repousser l'âge de départ à la retraite
qui pèsera sur la génération des tucs
puisque ce sont ces jeunes travailleurs
des années 80 qui sont aujourd'hui aux
portes de la retraite qui vont certes se
voir reconnaître quelques petits
trimestres qui leur sont dus
rappelons-le ce n'est que justice
rétablit mais qui devront en
contrepartie passer à les travailler
c'est ça la réalité de votre réforme
pour les tucs alors j'aurais aimé qu'on
fasse une réforme que pour les tucs ça
aurait été pour le coup justice donc
votre réforme c'est bien l'aboutissement
de votre projet de destruction et
d'affaiblissement de la protection
sociale au profit d'une dérégulation
sans limite et je le disais tout à
l'heure d'une négation du réel vous n'y
est que repousser l'âge de départ en
retraite pour les métiers difficiles
c'est alourdir la dette de la dépendance
et faire payer aux Français au prix de
leur vie vos réformes inutiles vous nier
la réalité budgétaire vous évoquez le
corps à longueur du discours et pourtant
son président Didier ici même et madame
la Présidente de la Commission est
témoin jeudi dernier que les dépenses de
retraite ne dérapent pas elles sont
relativement maîtrisées dans la plupart
des hypothèses et elle diminue plutôt à
terme mais vous préférez dans votre
négation faire payer aux salariés votre
politique injustes permettez-moi de
convoquer je j'aime cet auteur un
nouveau enfin le même auteur finalement
que le premier c'est vous-même ce
ministre votre réforme elle écarte
d’emblée la recherche d'autres recettes
notamment la mise à contribution de
l'ensemble des revenus en particulier
ceux
issus du capital entre les niches
fiscales et boucliers du même nombre
c'est un peu obsolète beaucoup pour être
pour être fait pour que l'effort ne
portent pas une fois de plus sur les
seuls salariés parce que votre réforme
elle porte uniquement sur les salariés
et pour finir
je finirai sur un exemple parce que on
parle de la chair des Français mais on
peut aussi évoquer leur vie leur vie que
vous allez briser Nadine elle est née en
avril 1963 elle a 168 trimestres tous
cotisés elle est assistante de direction
et elle souhaite quitter la région
parisienne pour monter un projet de vie
notamment s'occuper de sa mère
âgé et handicapé s'il vous plaît écoutez
Nadine elle devait partir en retraite le
1er octobre prochain avec votre effort
injuste ces deux ans de plus qui seront
nécessaires à Nadine pour construire sa
vie Nadine elle est pas seule elles sont
des millions les nadines des millions de
vie que vous allez briser dans leur
projet dans leur corps des millions de
Français qui sont aujourd'hui dans la
rue ils nous regardent ils vous
regardent soyez responsables et
raisonnable renoncer à ce projet
du paix sont ses coûts chers collègues
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre madame la Présidente cette
réforme nous le savons n'a pas de sens
pas de sens économique le système de
retraite est globalement résilient à
l'absorption des Baby Boom nous a dit au
FCE il n'y a pas d'envolée des dépenses
nous dit le corps il y a tout au plus un
ajustement à réaliser sur les recettes
du système de retraite ce qui finalement
n'a rien de surprenant après des années
que nous venons de passer et qui ont vu
les vannes ouvertes des aides aux
entreprises 157 milliards en dehors du
covid un tiers du budget de l'État une
drogue dure pour les entreprises pas de
sens social non plus deux ans de plus
pour tout le monde hop punition
collective vous avez travaillé dur
longtemps de manière pénible vous avez
travaillé de manière hachée ou au
contraire vous êtes parmi les plus les
mieux dotés du système d'emploi pas de
détails tout le monde a deux ans de plus
d'ailleurs on les voit vos petits
éléments de langage vos petites phrases
votre petit cynisme vous ne parlez plus
de pénibilité mais d'usure
professionnelle ce ne sont pas les
métiers ou les conditions d'emploi le
problème mais nos corps vous allez nous
rabâcher l'augmentation minimum de
retraite à 1200 euros que vous présentez
comme l'avancée sociale de cette réforme
première précision apportée par Olivier
Véran récemment la cible c'est 1200
euros en brut et finalement ça ne
concernera que 48 personnes je le répète
48 personnes la réforme n'a pas plus de
sens écologique produisez produisez
produisez quel est le seul sens de cette
réforme que produire nous envoie dans le
mur climatique pas de problème dans
effondrement j'arrête Diamond possède
question quels étaient les pensées de
celui qui a coupé le dernier arbre de
l'île de Pâques au moment où il l'a fait
et vous monsieur du soft quels sont vos
pensées au moment de défendre cette
réforme devant nous d'où vient votre
empressement à servir un système
mortifère de croissance et de
productivisme à l'heure où nos
conditions de vie sur Terre sont en
danger vous nous avez vendu l'école
rouler mais c'est maintenant qu'il faut
être écologiste la réforme est une
récompense la retraite pardon est une
récompense
un dieu légitime et juste pour celles et
ceux qui ont cotisé c'est un droit un
revenu différé diront les économistes
quelque chose missagement de côté pour
pouvoir un jour en jouir c'est de cela
dont il s'agit empêcher les gens de
jouir de profiter de ce qui leur
appartient un droit au repos à la
sérénité un droit à l'appareil durement
acquis enfin ma première question est
donc simple
pourquoi faites-vous cette réforme non
nécessaire si vous avez besoin de marge
budgétaire supplémentaires pourquoi vous
obstinez-vous à réduire les dépenses sur
le dos des travailleurs et des
travailleuses et des retraités plutôt
que d'aller chercher des recettes
supplémentaires deuxième question quand
sortira la loi rectificative du PLFSS
pour augmenter corrélativement le budget
de la Sécurité sociale car oui rappelons
que lorsque l'on augmente d'un an l'âge
de la retraite les dépenses de santé
augmentent d'un tiers des économies
réalisées sur le système de retraite où
le PLFSS rectificatif pour payer les
invalidités les maladies
professionnelles etc prévoyez-vous une
augmentation corrélative de la durée
d'indemnisation de l'assurance chômage
pour les personnes proches de la
retraite sans emploi qui voient leur
temps de précarité augmentée de deux ans
supplémentaires avant de toucher leur
retraite quatrième question quel est
l'impact écologique de la réforme des
retraites l'étude d'impact ne le précise
pas pour l'instant aucune étude d'impact
ne pose cette question à quel moment
pouvez-vous nous dire que le
productivisme n'aura aucun impact sur
nos émissions de carbone le climat et
l'environnement à combien estimez-vous
l'écart de niveau de vie des retraités
avant et après la réforme prochaine
question vous souhaitez agir contre la
pénibilité au travail allez-vous établir
de nouveaux critères de pénibilité je
pense par exemple aux femmes de ménage
particulièrement exposées aux produits
chimiques et cancérigènes qui n'en
bénéficient pas ou aux métiers soumis à
vibration comme les marteau-piqueurs qui
eux non plus n'en bénéficient pas
pouvez-vous nous dire de manière
concrète en quoi la situation pour les
femmes et les carrières hachées
sera-t-elle améliorée par votre réforme
car oui les premières victimes de votre
réforme seront les personnes
discriminées sur le marché du travail
très bien la parole est à Monsieur
Pierre d'arriville pour le groupe
gauche-démocrate et républicaine nupes
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre qu'est-ce que vous faites là
c'est pas une question personnelle je ne
comprends pas ce que vous faites là
ça fait des mois et des mois vous
préparez le terrain que vous polissez
vos éléments de langage mais jeudi
dernier vous avez rempli les rues de
toutes les vies du pays de manifestante
et de manifestants l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales et contre vous
votre projet recueille 15 à 30 %
d'opinion favorable dans les enquêtes
vous n'avez pas de majorité dans le pays
vous avez échoué
maintenant vous essayez pittueusement de
décourager les gens en leur disant que
vous êtes déterminé
déterminez à quoi déterminer pourquoi
pour ne pas perdre de temps je vous fais
aussi la réponse à sauver le système de
retraite avec un projet de justice
sociale répétez vous
même pas
il n'y aura que des perdants dans votre
monde alors n'essayez pas de nous vendre
des pianos le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites lui-même ne parle pas de
danger et vous qui avez passé votre
temps depuis votre élection avec cette
majorité à des financer la sécurité
sociale ne venez pas maintenant faire la
leçon il y a bien des pistes de
financement pour faire pièce aux besoins
de notre système de retraite et de
sécurité sociale personne ne vous
prendra pour des sauveurs ni pour des
partisans de la justice sociale ça n'est
pas crédible vous êtes des innocents
mains pleine votre projet c'est de
nouveau les meilleures années de
retraite et à défaut de raboter les
pensions des récalcitrantes et des
récalcitrants parce que les salariés les
retraités coûtent trop cher à vos yeux
et aux yeux de Bruxelles qui vous
encouragent votre projet c'est la
retraite pour se soigner c'est de
dégrader le droit à la retraite c'est de
nous faire payer plus cher notre droit à
la retraite c'est de dépenser moins pour
les retraites parce que oui nos
retraites vous coûtent cher
et ça fait depuis le début depuis leur
existence que les retraites coûtent trop
cher aux yeux de certaines et de
certains
mais dans votre système tout le monde
passerait à la caisse et certains
évidemment au regard de leur parcours
professionnel payeraient deux fois plus
cher toujours les mêmes le seul crédit
que je peux vous faire c'est d'être
habile dans la fiction de concertation
je n'en rajoute pas là dessus les
organisations syndicales l'ont bien
démontré avec et remerciements que vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure qui ne sont
pas réciproques si j'ai bien compris
fiction de débat parlementaire avec un
débat cadré par la procédure budgétaire
déjà cadenas assez d'avance fiction
autour du travail des seniors réalité
que vous refusez en réalité de regarder
en face vous nous promettez un index
vous connaissez le proverbe dans le sage
montre la lune
je vous passe la suite vous me
permettrez de vous dire que vous êtes
disqualifié pour parler de la pénibilité
au regard des premières mesures qui ont
été prises sous le quinquennat de
François Hollande de Emmanuel Macron en
2017 mesure qui avait été installé sous
le mandat précédent de François Hollande
vous êtes disqualifié pour parler de la
pénibilité donc pour parler du niveau
des pensions
et dans toute la société c'est mesures
au rang des effets sa réforme aurait des
effets feraient des dégâts considérables
et y compris auraient des effets sur les
plus jeunes évidemment prendre dans la
caisse ATMP accident du travail maladie
professionnelle est une indemnité pour
quelques petites avancées vous nous
imposer un recul considérable qui
s'imposera à tous et vous allez faire
payer le prix fort rien ne saurait
rendre acceptable ce projet même si j'ai
vu que vous passiez très vite sur le
cœur de votre projet pour nous parler de
ce que vous avez rager à rajouter
ensuite pour essayer de faire passer la
pilule nous voulons le droit à une
nouvelle étape de la vie comme le disait
Ambroise Croizat vous voulez nous
voulons préserver ce droit essentiel qui
est un grand geste de civilisation être
libéré du travail prescrit avoir au bout
de sa vie professionnelle un formidable
espace de liberté un droit précieux à
chacune à chacun mais aussi à toutes et
à tous à toute la société c'est une
question de projet de société
effectivement ça vient contradiction
avec
cette vision de l'humain productif et
compétitif nous nous voulons l'humain
épanoui dans son travail et dans sa vie
la question que vous devriez vous poser
c'est plutôt comment préserver ce droit
et ce n'est pas ce que vous faites
monsieur le ministre le pays n'en veut
pas de cette réforme brutale injuste
injustifiée et illégitime alors il n'y a
pas des motivités de sensibles riz
lorsqu'on touche droit à la retraite
c'est une question sociale on touche à
des réalités sociales évidemment on
vient impacter nos vies et votre
entêtement vous-même illégitime à force
nous nous racontait pas des sornettes en
brandissant le programme présidentiel
l'esprit de responsabilité le respect de
la volonté populaire voilà qui devrait
vous guider à la place où vous êtes
notre République fragilisée ne peut pas
se permettre le passage en force et le
pourrissement et éviter le paternalisme
en nous expliquant que c'est pour notre
bien vous n'avez pas de majorité
populaire il va falloir vous mettre dans
la tête que ça ne passe pas il va bien
falloir que l'hypothèse d'un abandon du
projet fasse son chemin dans vos têtes
vous êtes en fâcheuse posture monsieur
le ministre je ne comprends pas ce que
vous faites là vous faites encore là il
faut rentrer maintenant avec votre
réforme sous le bras retirez votre
monsieur le député franchement
je me permets de répondre une fois n'est
pas coutume que fait que fait le
ministre là il a répondu à notre
invitation monsieur le député c'est la
moindre des choses c'est de respecter
s'il vous plaît et si la vie décliné
l'invitation vous auriez dit qu'il a
manqué de courage pour ne pas dire autre
chose
très bien donc et un peu de respect
voilà par rapport aux invités que nous
recevons dans le cadre de la commission
monsieur le député voilà la parole la
parole
la parole est à Monsieur Charles de
Courson pour liberté indépendant
outre-mer
madame la Présidente de la Commission
monsieur le ministre madame le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre votre projet tout
d'abord n'a pas de légitimité
démocratique contrairement à ce que dit
le président de la République les
Français n'ont pas élu pour réformer les
retraites en portant de 62 à 65 ans
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite en
effet la moitié des électeurs qui ont
voté pour lui au deuxième tour moi le
premier d'ailleurs n'approuvait pas
cette mesure de son programme et
d'ailleurs un mois plus tard aux
élections législatives la majorité
sortante a obtenu 25% des voix au
premier tour et une minorité de siège
dans notre assemblée les sondages
confirment d'ailleurs ce rejet 76% des
actifs sont contre donc 79% des ouvriers
des employés même 46% des retraités qui
ne sont pourtant pas concernés ils sont
opposés
vous nous présenter votre forme comme
juste socialement et permettant de
redresser les comptes hot votre réforme
n'est pas juste et il y avait d'autres
manières d'assurer l'équilibre des
comptes des 42 régimes de retraite
existants elle est tout d'abord injuste
car ceux qui vont la subir sont ceux qui
ont commencé tôt et qui exercent parfois
des métiers pénibles notre groupe lui
est hostile au recul de l'âge légal de
62 du régime général qui va s'abattre
comme un coup près dans une tribune
publiée en 2021 nous posions une
question simple à la fin de l'openbach
budgétaire qui paiera l'addition avec ce
texte vous apportez une réponse les
Français qui commencent à travailler tôt
pourquoi n'agissez-vous pas sur la
surcote en la majorant
qui est une vraie incitation à rester au
travail
concentrez le débat sur l'âge de 64 ans
c'est exactement ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire et les mobilisations massives de
jeudi dernier le prouve quant aux
mesures en faveur de la pénibilité
malgré quelques programmes elles sont
également insuffisantes et difficiles à
mettre en œuvre parce que vous appuyez
pas suffisamment sur des négociations
par branche entre les partenaires
sociaux votre forme elle est aussi
injuste car il y a peu de mesure à
destination des familles notamment des
femmes à l'exception des congés de de
parentaux d'éducation dont vous prenez
en compte cette durée alors que leur
pension de droit direct sont inférieurs
de 40% celle des hommes nous proposons
nous de généraliser à 57 ans l'âge légal
pour bénéficier de la pension de
réversion et de généraliser et de
remonter les plafonds de cumul nous
proposons aussi d'uniformiser
d'améliorer les règles en matière de
majoration de pension de durée
d'assurance pour enfants il faut régler
aussi le problème des conjoints divorcés
d'ailleurs que vous avez demandé au
corps une étude sur endroit familiaux
que vous jugez vous même dans votre
interview JDD dimanche dernier je cite
de véritables nids à inégalité tant ils
sont divers selon les régimes alors
êtes-vous ouvert à des amendements en ce
sens votre réforme est d'autant plus
injuste que vous ne traitez pas vraiment
d'un sujet essentiel pour l'avenir du
système l'emploi des seniors nous avons
besoin d'un vrai plan visant à augmenter
les taux d'activité des seniors la
création d'un index senior ne retournera
pas le problème il faut une plus grosse
effort de la part des entreprises
notamment en termes de formation et de
reclassement pour ces personnes et
pourquoi ne pas réfléchir à mécanisme
d'ailleurs de dégressivité de
cotisations sociales au-delà de 55 ans
il faut aussi prévoir des aménagements
de fin de carrière bien plus attractive
vous faites un pas positif en faveur du
cumul emploi retraite et de la retraite
progressive il faudrait aller plus loin
pour que la liberté des assurés soit la
règle enfin votre réforme est injuste
car vous mettez en extinction 5 régimes
spéciaux et non les autres dans le
précédent mandat vous avez échoué à
faire une réforme systémique en voulant
créer un 43e régime de retraite
aujourd'hui vous faites une réforme
essentiellement paramétrique et très
subsidiairement systémique sans aucune
cohérence pourquoi par exemple
écartez-vous le régime spécial de
l'Assemblée nationale ou du Sénat alors
que vous mettez en extinction dans une
spéciale des membres du 16e pourquoi
maintenant les régimes spéciaux de
l'Opéra de Paris de la Comédie Française
et de Lénine notre groupe lui défend une
réforme des retraites de justice et de
liberté or sur les 17 milliards d'euros
d'économies et qui ne tiennent pas en
compte des surcos sur notamment le
régime d'assurance chômage et sur le RSA
que certains estiment à un tiers des
économies seul un tiers de ces économies
brutes iront financer dispositifs de
solidarité donc ce n'est pas une loi de
justice sociale de la tentons par
ailleurs que vous précisiez aujourd'hui
ce que vous proposez en matière de
carrière longue et de retraite minimale
quels seront les conditions exactes
d'accès et combien d'assurer seront
réellement concernés par ces mesures
très attendues
dans votre texte vous renvoyez beaucoup
d'éléments à des décrets en état votre
projet de réforme des retraites n'est
pas vraiment une réforme tout est
d'ailleurs prévu dès la présentation du
programme de stabilité vous écrivez noir
sur blanc la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques repose principalement sur la
forme structurelle la réforme de
retraite notamment de font dire qu'il
faut s'attaquer au déficit mais affirmer
qu'ils mettent en péril notre système de
répartition est inexact exagéré nous
avons encore le temps de trouver
d'autres solutions qui finalise pas les
salariés les plus modestes et les
classes moyennes encore une fois en
conclusion notre groupe est prêt à
soutenir une réforme des retraites de
liberté et de justice sociale mais ce
n'est pas ce que vous nous proposez
sur le député donc mes chers collègues
avant de vous repasser la parole pour
des questions si vous me le permettez je
vais passer la parole à Monsieur le
Ministre pour nous donner déjà des
éléments de réponse à toutes ces
nombreuses questions monsieur le
ministre merci madame la Présidente les
questions sont nombreuses vous l'avez
dit je vais essayer de d'y répondre dans
l'ordre tout en évitant un certain
nombre de redit puisque certains sujets
se croisent d'abord dire peut-être que
la réforme que nous proposons va
permettre je l'ai dit de dégager des
marges de manœuvre pour le seul système
de retraite à hauteur 18 milliards
d'euros mais évidemment ces mesures que
nous prenons avec le recul de l'âge de
départ avec les mesures d'accompagnement
qui sont celles que nous proposons
doivent aussi avoir un impact sur
l'emploi nous estimons que c'est la
consigne conséquence positive avec
environ le maintien d'emploi d'environ
300 000 personnes en 2030 350 000
ensuite il y a une augmentation du taux
d'emploi des seniors que nous visons à
hauteur de six points c'est que
évidemment un effet bénéfique sur la
croissance en supposant un lien direct
un moyen terme entre l'emploi
supplémentaire et le PIB on estime que
le surcroît de croissance sera de
l'ordre de un point de PIB ce qui sera
évidemment bénéfique pour les finances
publiques cela permettra évidemment de
ne jamais revenir sur un principe que
j'ai répété dans mon intervention
luminaire pas un euro de cotisation
vieillesse ne finance autre chose qui
est des retraites mais s'il y a
augmentation du PIB il aura évidemment
augmentation de la richesse produite et
d'un certain nombre d'autres d'un
certain nombre d'autres contributions
fiscales ou sociales pour continuer sur
les questions posées par madame le
rapporteur général nous estimons que la
réforme va permettre d'augmenter la
pension à la liquidation indépendamment
de tout autre considération uniquement
par les effets de la réforme de 1 de 1 à
2%. mais que c'est ces gains sont en
réalité concentrés sur les 30% de
pension les plus petites celles qui sont
aujourd'hui globalement inférieurs à
1000 euros qui elle augmenteront plutôt
de 5% indépendamment de l'application de
la retraite garantie et pour les femmes
dont les gains seront globalement deux
fois plus importants que les hommes pour
un certain nombre de mécanismes sur
lesquels je reviendrai à l'occasion de
répondre aux questions
s'explique à la fois par l'augmentation
de la durée d'activité par la hausse des
mini pas de pension par des droits
générés aussi notamment pendant les
périodes de cumulent en plein retraite
ou l'intégration pour l'éligibilité au
minimum de pension d'un certain nombre
de trimestre au titre de l'assurance
vieillesse pour les parents au foyer
quand il s'agit de regarder les effets
redistributifs et de voir comment 40 %
de nos concitoyens qui sont dans les
situations les plus fragiles puissent
partir à la retraite de manière
anticipée vous m'interrogez madame le
rapporteur sur ce qui recouvre ce qui
recouvre les 40% de départ anticipés les
propositions sont assez variables en
général selon les générations mais ce
que l'on retient c'est que au niveau de
la génération 61-62 les 40% de départ
anticipés sont composés de 15 points de
départ pour invalidité ou pour
incapacité sur avis médical 20 points un
peu plus entre 20 et 22 points cela
dépend des générations au titre du
bénéfice des départs pour carrière
longue et 5 points 5% bénéficient d'un
départ anticipé au type d'autres
dispositif cela peut être lié à la
mobilisation des points de C2P cela peut
être lié à des questions de l'incapacité
permanente dans la fonction publique
cela peut être lié à des retraites
progressives ou encore des départs
anticipés pour amiante pour exposition à
l'amiante pardon pour handicap ou encore
au bénéfice des catégories actives ainsi
nous avons
40%, blancs en allant si je puis dire
des assurés qui partent à la retraite
avec
sans attendre qui partent en tête chaque
année pardon sans avoir atteint l'âge
légal faut souligner un autre chiffre
mais qui est à l'opposé du spectre qui
est qu'aujourd'hui 15 % des assurés
partent à 67 ans et non pas à 62 n'ont
pas 63 qui est l'âge de départ
effectivement mais à 67 ans et avec deux
cas de figure d'abord mais de manière
très minoritaire des hommes et des
femmes qui exercent des métiers qui sont
souvent des métiers passionnants des
métiers relevant de l'enseignement
relevant de l'encadrement supérieur de
la fonction publique d'État ou de la
fonction publique territoriale de la
médecine mais aussi et c'est l'essentiel
des cas des hommes et des femmes qui
travaillent jusqu'à 67 ans pour diminuer
l'impact de la décote entre 62 et 67 ans
et lorsqu'on parle de cette immense
majorité de cas on parle pour beaucoup
de femmes qui confrontaient à des
interruptions de carrière doivent aller
aussi longtemps et souvent que nous
retrouvons exerçant des métiers assez
difficiles comme l'aide à domicile la
garde d'enfants ou encore les métiers du
soin et du médico-social enfin Madame la
rapporteur général vous m'avez interrogé
sur la manière dont nous voulons
mobiliser le milliard d'euros sur
l'ensemble de la législature pour le
financement du fond de prévention de
l'usure professionnelle et la pénibilité
ce fond sera géré par la branche ATMP
puisque c'est cette branche qui va le
financer à hauteur de 200 millions
d'euros par an au régime de croisière
c'est quelque chose de considérable
puisque aujourd'hui la bonté MP consacre
40 millions d'euros par an et non pas
200 la prévention de la pénibilité donc
c'est un véritable changement d'échelle
et nous souhaitons que ces financements
sur la branche ATMP puisse accompagner
la mise en oeuvre de plantes prévention
métier par métier branche par branche
pour faire en sorte que le nombre de
départ pour un capacité pour inaptitude
les 100 000 que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure soit réduit parce qu'en réalité
il n'est pas satisfaisant de dire ou de
considérer comme pas juste de considérer
que un des participer de deux ans de
trois ans de 4 ans d'un salarié qui est
abimé par son travail et la bonne
réponse à la pénibilité je préfère mille
fois qu'un salarié puisse aller jusqu'à
l'âge légal dans bonne condition de
santé en bonne forme pour bénéficier
d'une retraite en bonne forme à l'âge
légal plutôt qu'un salarié qui part deux
ans ou 3 ans avant parce qu'il a le dos
brisé parce qu'il a le dos bloqué et que
son travail a finalement abîmé abîmé son
organisme je fais une parenthèse parce
que ça a été évoqué à plusieurs reprises
pour dire que sur la branche ATMP les
prévisions qui sont celles de la branche
prévoit un excédent en 2026 à hauteur de
3,3 milliards d'euros une fois retraité
le virement classiquement adopté par le
Parlement à l'occasion de l'examen des
pellets FSS pour compenser les
sous-déclarations auprès de la Caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie et donc si
vous me permettez cette expression c'est
3,3 milliards d'euros d'excédents net
avec
la hausse du taux de la CNAV et la
baisse du taux de la TPMP que nous
proposons pour assurer le financement du
système de retraite cet accident sera
encore supérieur à 2 milliards d'euros
et c'est excellent de plus de 2
milliards d'euros autorise évidemment le
financement de 200 millions d'euros par
an et même peut-être un peu plus en
matière de prévention de la pénibilité
je dis pour souligner combien il n'y a
pas de risque en la matière à mobiliser
financement et je le dis aussi en
soulignant que 3,3 milliards d'euros
c'est 20% du total des recettes de la
branche ATMP et qui a un excédent égal à
20% des recettes justifie aussi que nous
puissions mobiliser plus de ses moyens
pour le financement de la prévention et
et de la prévention de la prévention de
l'usure et de la pénibilité sur les
différents points qui ont été évoqués
ensuite par les autres orateurs d'abord
dire que nous avons la volonté ça a été
évoqué plusieurs reprises de mieux
protéger ce qui commence à travailler
tôt et j'entends le débat sur le fait
qu'un certain nombre d'assurés aurait
finalement à travailler jusqu'à 40 ans
pour bénéficier d'une carrière à taux
plein nous l'avons dit nous n'allons pas
plus loin que la réforme de 2013 la
réforme des Touraine qui est un poste 43
années minimum de cotisations pour
bénéficier d'une carrière à taux plein
mais nous savons aujourd'hui aussi que
nous sommes dans un système qui fait
canner après année sur les un peu moins
de 800 000 départs à la retraite que
nous connaissons 180 000 concerne des
assurés qui ont plus que le nombre de
trimestres et si je devais prendre un
seul exemple pour faire écho à des
débats de l'actualité récente nous
parlons beaucoup ces derniers jours de
ceux qui commencent à travailler à 20h
mais qu'aurions-nous du dire
collectivement de ceux qui au cours des
10 dernières années on commençait leur
carrière un peu après 19 ans non pas pu
bénéficier du système de carrière longue
doivent aller jusqu'à 62 ans et travail
43 ans alors que le système en l'État
impose 42 années de cotisation
qu'aurions-nous dû dire et je ne dis pas
que c'était bien je dis que les réformes
successives ont corrigé de ceux qui
avant 2010 avant qu'il existe le système
de carrière longue commencez leur
carrière à 14-15 ans et devait aller
jusqu'à 60 ans soi-disant 45 ou 46 ans
je prends ces exemples non pas pour dire
que c'était une bonne situation je vais
prendre simplement pour dire que nous
sommes dans un système qui porte un
centre de paramètres d'âge de date de
naissance de durée de cotisation et qui
évidemment il y a toujours des effets de
seuil pour ne pas dire des effets de
bord et que notre objectif est de les
réduire et avec ce que nous faisons sur
l'amélioration de l'accès au départ
anticipé à 58 ans pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler très tôt avec la
borne que nous créons pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 16 et 18 ans
en réalité mais peut-être qu'on peut
trouver ça insatisfaisant et je
l'entends mais en réalité nous en sorte
de rapprocher le plus possible et je ne
dis pas que c'est parfaitement réussi
mais le rapprocher le plus possible
l'écart de durée de cotisation entre
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler plus
tôt et ceux qui commencent à travailler
plus tard et globalement de rapprocher
le plus possible l'écart de cotisations
de durée de cotisation tout court entre
les différents assurés que nous allons
arriver à un point où cette écart n'aura
jamais été aussi faible et c'est tant
mieux est-ce que c'est satisfaisant
est-ce que c'est perfectible je ne suis
pas sûr de la perfection soit de ce
monde quand on est dans un système
paramétrique mais en tout cas c'est un
progrès qu'il faut souligner vous avez
monsieur Maillard évoqué les questions
de pénibilité d'autres un prix vous
l'ont fait et je voudrais simplement
dire que nous avons à la fois fait le
choix d'améliorer le CP et lorsque nous
améliorons le C2P sur les questions
investissement des seuils de prise en
charge de la police position de création
d'une nouvelle utilisation du C2P
évidemment ce sont des mesures qui vont
dans le bon sens et qui sont d'ailleurs
plutôt saluées par nos interlocuteurs y
compris lorsqu'ils ne partagent pas
le relèvement de l'âge de départ il y a
quatre critères qui ont été exclus du
C2P du C3P devenu ces deux P en 2017 un
premier critère madame Rousseau a évoqué
il y a un instant qui est l'exposition
un risque chimique aucun de nos
interlocuteurs partenaires sociaux nous
a demandé la réintégration en tant que
tel dans le C2P et nous partageons un
point c'est le fait que l'exposition a
des risques chimiques peut amener pour
ceux qui ont déjà été exposés à une
forme de prévalence des maladies
professionnelles qu'il faut mieux suivre
mieux prévenir et s'il s'agit
malheureusement de réparer par contre
pour ceux qui travaillent aujourd'hui et
qui travailleront demain pour nous
l'exposition au risque d'agence
chimiques ne relève pas d'une pénibilité
qu'il faudrait accepter mais d'une
interdiction pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'exposition c'est en cela que nous
avons cette approche peut-être
différente de ce que vous avez évoqué
les trois autres critères sont des
critères ergonomiques les vibrations le
port de charge lourdes les postures
pénibles et si nous les réintégrons pas
dans le C2P en tant que tel se sont
autour de ces trois critères que seront
déterminés par la branche ATMP sur la
base de l'accidentologie sur la base de
la prévalence des maladies
professionnelles sur la base une enquête
qui s'appelle l'enquête summer qui
permet d'examiner la qualité et les
conditions de travail c'est sur cette
base là et autour de ces trois critères
que ce sont déterminés les métiers les
plus potentiellement exposés à la
pénibilité soit faisant l'objet de
discussions obligatoires des branches et
de conclusion obligatoire d'accord pour
la prévention accord qui seront financés
comme j'ai indiqué il y a un instant et
c'est pour ces métiers là que nous
mettons en place un suivi médical
renforcé de manière à garantir
l'effectivité des départs anticipés
après avis médical c'est d'ailleurs un
des points divergences avec certaines
organisations syndicales qui
souhaiteraient que ce soit un droit
automatique alors que nous voulons tenir
compte de l'effectivité de l'exposition
ça n'est pas la même chose d'être
menuisier sur un chantier en extérieur
ou modifier dans un atelier sur une
machine la commande numérique alors que
d'un point de vue administratif c'est le
même code la même nomenclature métier
d'où la nécessité de prendre en compte
l'effectivité des conditions
d'autres questions étaient posées sur la
question des effets de bord c'est le cas
de l'orateur du rassemblement national
de celui de la France insoumise de
Madame Rousseau ou encore pardonnez-moi
je tiens j'essaye d'être exhaustif de
Monsieur d'arrivée
le risque d'un effet de bord sur
d'autres branches de la sécurité sociale
serait évidemment forme d'illusion ou
idéale qu'on atteint que rarement par
contre nous avons pris un certain nombre
de mesures qui permettent de minimiser
ce risque de départ le fait de maintenir
la possibilité d'un départ anticipé à 55
ans et travailleur handicapés à 62 ans
pour ceux qui sont victimes d'une
incapacité ou d'une aptitude de rendre
automatique et sans avis médical le
droit au départ anticipé pour ceux qui
sont l'objet se sont vus attribués un
taux d'incapacité supérieure à 20% à la
suite d'un accident du travail ou d'une
maladie professionnelle c'est la
garantie de maintenir dans le système de
retraite
le coût parce que malheureusement on
parle d'argent mais le coût des pensions
versées à celles et ceux qui si nous
n'avions pas pris ces mesures pourraient
effectivement basculer sur d'autres
branches de la sécurité sociale et
d'autres régimes de protection et donc
je vous dis ça pour dire que nous ne
partageons pas les inquiétudes que vous
avez exprimées et que les mesures que
nous avons prises notamment celles que
j'ai évoqué d'autres permettent de
limiter cette question des effets de
bord sur la tension pour les plus
fragiles j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
en réponse à Madame Rist ce sont
vraiment les retraités des trois
premiers les cils qui bénéficieront des
plus fortes hausses de de pension
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure que les
retraités n'étaient pas des lignes Excel
qu'on manipule depuis Bercy alors ça
tombe plutôt bien parce que j'ai quitté
Bercy et effectivement les retraités ne
sont pas l'objet de ligne Excel ils ne
sont pas l'objet de tableur mais ils ne
sont pas non plus ils ne doivent pas
être non plus l'objet de slogan trompeur
ou de tractement songé nous travaillons
pour faire en sorte que les plus
fragiles justement soient prises en
compte et nous travaillons pour faire en
sorte que les mesures que nous prenons
qui ont un caractère paramétrique soit
les plus adaptés les plus adaptables
possibles aux possibilités et à la
situation effective rencontrer par
l'ensemble des travailleurs concernés
c'est vraiment je le répète un point
d'attention et nous aurons l'occasion
dans le débat point par point de revenir
sur les éléments que nous avons avec la
première mise choisie de modifier choisi
de compter parfois pour justement
protéger les plus fragiles il y a eu
ensuite un point sur la question de la
retraite minimum et de cette garantie
que nous voulons créer d'une retraite
égale à 85% du SMIC
s'agit de 85 % du speaknet ce qui
correspond presque à 1200 euros dans les
prévisions qui sont les notes pour la
fin de l'année 2023 et sur ces 1200
euros ou à peu près 1200 euros ne
portera qu'un seul prélèvement la CSG
avec un taux qui peut être à 0 un taux
qui peut être à 3,8 % ou un taux qui
peut être majoré pourquoi est-ce que
nous restons dans cette forme de flot
d'arborescence parce que le taux de CSG
qui s'appliquera assez pension minimum
garantie ne dépend pas du niveau du
niveau de pension de l'assuré mais
dépend du foyer du revenu du foyer
fiscal auquel il appartient parce que
nous avons un système social qui
familiarisait la CSG fait partie des
contributions dans le montant dans le
poids est calculé en fonction du foyer
du revenu du foyer fiscal cela varie
entre 0 et 3,8 il y a un taux majoré
mais globalement je pense qu'on pourra
toujours me trouver une exception à la
règle celles et ceux qui vont bénéficier
de ce minimum de pension garantie à 85%
du SMIC autour de 1200 appartiennent
rarement à des foyers fiscaux dont le
revenu global amène à être assujetti ou
en tout cas mise à contribution sur un
taux qui serait majoré monsieur Bazin a
évoqué plusieurs aspects mais il y en a
trois sur lesquels je souhaite revenir
quatre pardon sur lesquels je souhaite
revenir tout particulièrement le premier
concerne la question des droits
familiaux et cela fait quoi à
l'intervention de Monsieur de course je
partage le constat que vous faites quand
vous dites qu'il existe 11 système de
pension de réversion différents je
pensais même que c'était 13 mais que ce
soit 11 ou 13 ça ne fait qu'ajouter à la
complexité et ça n'enlève rien à la
complexité c'était 11 plutôt que 13 je
sais aussi qu'il y a un manque
d'harmonisation en matière de majoration
des durées de cotisations
avoir un enfant parce que cela fait
partie des éléments qui génèrent des
droits familiaux c'est 8 trimestres dans
le secteur privé c'est 4 trimestre dans
le secteur public et cette différence
est expliquée par l'histoire plus que
par la réalité sur le fait que
les agents publics auraient une
perspective de carrière plus stable que
les salariés du privé que c'est la
raison pour laquelle cette différence
pouvait être
acceptée nous avons effectivement
demandé au Conseil d'orientation des
retraites de travailler sur ce sujet là
nous avons la conviction que les
parlementaires se saisiront du sujet
vous l'avez fait à de nombreuses
reprises nous avançons quelques
propositions et quelques dispositions
dans le texte autour de l'intégration de
trimestre cotisé au titre de l'assurance
vieillesse des parents au foyer tant
pour les éligibilité au minimum de
pension et notamment myco majoré que
pour les ligibilité au bénéfice
d'indépendancesicipés pour carrière
longue nous avons cette conviction qu'il
faut avancer sur ce sujet là mais la
conviction aussi que ce sujet vous le
savez tous est tellement complexe que ça
nécessite un tout petit peu de temps et
que nous puissions nous appuyer sur les
travaux que j'ai évoqué nous nous
croisons cela évidemment avec notre
mesure qui concerne les aidants vous
l'avez souligné je le disais juste pour
mémoire vous m'avez ensuite interrogé
sur la date d'entrée en vigueur en
réalité si le député la réflexion
pourrait être plus facilement entendu ou
entendable si la date du 1er septembre
ne concernait que le premier palier avec
un relèvement de trois mois de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits mais la réforme
est un tout et au 1er septembre c'est
aussi la majoration de 100 euros des
retraités qui prendront leur retraite
avec une carrière complète au niveau du
SMIC c'est la prise en compte des tubes
que vous avez évoqué c'est la mise en
place du cumulant retraite créateur de
droit c'est la revalorisation et le
début de la revalorisation des retraités
actuels et donc c'est vraiment toutes
ces mesures positives ou d'efforts parce
que c'est un effort que nous demandons
qui sont mises en place au 1er septembre
et qui font que nous sommes attachés à
cette unité de date pour la mise en
œuvre sur la fiabilité des simulateurs
de manière conjoncturelle pour répondre
aux questions que se posent des assurant
périodes de réforme comme de manière
structurelle pour que dans le temps les
assurer des réponses rapides et qui sont
les plus fiables possibles c'est le cœur
des discussions que nous avons dans le
cadre de la convention d'objectifs et de
moyens avec la Caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse justement pour
que ce soit le plus amélioré possible et
différences simulateurs vont être
rapidement mis en oeuvre enfin un point
sur votre attention porté
la question des revenus équivalents au
SMIC et notamment la question des
indépendants il y a deux réponses à cela
puisque les indépendants peuvent
effectivement par leur assiette de
cotisation et par la nature plus
volatile de leurs revenus être pénalisé
dans l'accès à la garantie de retraite
la première réponse tient dans le fait
que nous allons ouvrir et que nous
voulons que ça soit applicable en 2024
dans le cadre du prochain pvss la
réforme de l'assiette de cotisation des
indépendants pour qu'un niveau de
cotisation égale il y a un droit égal
pour les futurs et par ailleurs nous
travaillons avec la cpsti la caisse de
protection sociale des travailleurs
indépendants et notamment avec
l'organisation d'employeurs qui est la
plus représentée au sein de cpti là en
l'occurrence la CPME pour voir comment y
compris en mobilisant parfois les
réserves de cette caisse qui sont assez
conséquentes nous pouvons garantir et
comment nous allons garantir de manière
affective l'accès à la retraite minimum
à 85 % du SMIC pour une carrière
complète c'est ça n'est pas législatif
ça n'est pas de l'ordre du PLFSS on va
parfois sur des autorisations données à
la caisse d'engager des dépenses qui
sont inhabituelles comme nous l'avions
fait en période de covid pour permettre
à la caisse d'apporter des aides
sociales en plus de ce que nous avions
fait ou pour justement pallier des
difficultés d'accès de certains
indépendants aux éléments aux éléments
d'aide que nous avons mis en oeuvre pour
agir car coach n'y revient pas vous
l'avez vous l'avez sous le nom
monsieur Vigier a évoqué l'emploi des
seniors je n'y reviens pas j'ai donné la
réponse en même temps que Madame Rist
sur la question de la pénibilité nous
allons effectivement déplafonner la
possibilité d'acquérir d'obtenir par des
points anti du C2P et parmi les
utilisations des points de pays il y a
effectivement la possibilité d'obtenir
des trimestres de départ en si peu le
déplafonnement permettra d'obtenir plus
de trimestre de départ anticiper à du
proportion de cette acquisition nous
allons faire en sorte que le cumul
emploi retraite soit le contributif et
nous aurons dans le cadre d'un futur
projet de loi article tout cela avec la
mise en place du Compte Épargne Temps
Universel dernière question pardon
j'accélère un peu mais
sur la question du minimum contributif
nous savons que ce sont 200 000
retraités par an sur les 800 000 départs
sont 1/4 qui va bénéficier d'une
revalorisation de sa pension grâce à la
mise en oeuvre de cette garantie par
rapport à une situation cette garantie
n'existerait pas pour une retraite
complète au niveau du SMIC autour de 100
euros pour une carrière complète ces
environs 100 euros pour une carrière
incomplète ça serait évidemment
proratisé et nous allons procéder pour
les nouveaux retraités par une
augmentation de 75 euros du minimum
contributifs majoré de 25 euros minimum
contributif contributif de base pour
avoir le schéma le plus protecteur
possible monsieur Delaporte au-delà du
fait que vous avez de bons auteurs que
je salue systématiquement je voudrais
simplement vous dire que vous avez voulu
articuler votre propos pour trois mots
injustice vive et défaite en réalité la
vraie injustice c'est lorsque j'entends
le responsable de votre partie défendre
la retraite à 60 ans avec 43 années de
cotisation parce que ça c'est une
machine à décote et à petite pension le
vrai vide c'est celui de votre
proposition et je crois que plus
fondamentalement encore la vraie défaite
c'est lorsque l'on dit son attachement
un système de gestion paritaire et par
répartition tout en proposant de le
mettre sous perfusion de revenus du
capital parce que finalement une abandon
même du fond des fondamentaux du système
par répartition les effets de bord que
vous avez évoqué nous avons répondu je
crois tout comme sur les écarts de
revenus madame Rousseau a évoqué le
rapport du corps ce rapport je le
précise parce que c'est peut-être
toujours nécessaire
s'appuie sur différentes hypothèses
macroéconomiques et nous retenons
l'hypothèse centrale celle qui a
toujours été retenu il s'appuie sur deux
conventions comptables il s'appuie sur
deux conventions comptables
de convention c'est ce que je vous dis à
l'instant quatre hypothèses qui sont des
hypothèses de croissance économique et
deux conventions comptables qu'on peut
qualifier d'hypothèses comptables je
vous assure que si la convention
comptable c'est la convention équilibre
par régime et la deuxième convention
comptable c'est l'équilibre est fort des
inconstant l'équilibre à effort de ta
constant ça n'existe pas c'est une
convention comptable sur laquelle le
corps s'appuie qui n'a jamais été mise
en oeuvre et qui consiste à imaginer que
la part des recettes versées par l'État
au système de retraite par la
surcotisation de l'employeur état par le
subventionnement des régimes spéciaux
représentent quelques points de PIB et
que cet effort de l'État sous forme de
points de pipe verset au système de
retraite restaurer constant quel que
soit le nombre d'agents publics et de
pensionnés de l'État c'est en cela que
ça n'existe pas et donc nous travaillons
dans ce qui existe c'est à dire
l'équilibre par régime et dans le cadre
de l'équipe par régime les déficits sont
chroniques et l'hypothèse centrale qui
repose sur des hypothèses que tout le
monde macroéconomique que tout le monde
a toujours valider sont des hypothèses
qui montrent qu'il y a une dégradation
constante du déficit et je le répète ne
s'arrêter qu'aux poids des dépenses de
retraite dans le PIB au-delà du fait que
nous sommes le pays avec l'Italie en
Europe avoir le poil plus lourd avec
moyenne à 14 % contre 11 dans les autres
États membres ne s'arrêtait qu'au poids
de la dépense par rapport au PIB sans
tenir compte des recettes et donc du sol
et de la dégradation du sol mais à nos
yeux pas responsable et même le système
dans le mur sur le minimum de pension et
les critères de pénibilité je crois vous
avoir répondu tout comme j'ai répondu à
Monsieur dareville sur la question de la
TP et de la mobilisation des fonds de la
TNT pour monsieur de Courson j'ai
répondu sur la question des droits
familiaux je reviens je suis tout à fait
ouvert à ce que nous puissions discuter
dans le débat à venir des questions de
surcote et de mise en oeuvre de celle-ci
je vous dis simplement deux mots sur les
autres points que vous avez évoqués sur
trois points pardonnez-moi
le premier concerne ce que vous avez
qualifié vous-même d'interrogation sur
la légitimité démocratique je dis
simplement comme j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de le dire dans d'autres lieux et dans
d'autres murs que le Président de la
République et les députés de la majorité
quand il l'a fait campagne quand ils ont
fait campagne ont annoncer une réforme
avec un relèvement de l'âge à 65 ans
certains électeurs ont pu voter pour lui
et pour eux pour cela d'autres ont voté
pour ont voté contre lui et contre eux
pour à cause de cela certains ont voté
pour le président de la République
malgré cette réforme et sans la soutenir
par contre ce que je dis c'est que le
Président de la République d'une part a
été élu c'est un constat mais ce que je
dis c'est que personne n'est surpris de
cette réforme que personne n'est surpris
que nous l'amenions dans la mesure elle
a été annoncée et que cette transparence
sur les intentions est aussi une forme
de légitimité qu'il faut souligner la
deuxième chose que je vais évoquer
monsieur de Courson concerne les droits
familiaux je ne reviens pas sur
la question de l'harmonisation et la
réponse que j'ai faite précédemment à
Monsieur Bazin simplement vous dire que
vous avez évoqué un écart de pension
moyen de 40% entre les femmes et les
hommes pour la génération 1961 celle qui
prend sa retraite cette année nous
estimons que cet écart sera plutôt de
l'ordre de 30 % et pour la génération 71
sous l'effet conjugué des évolutions
sociologiques et des mesures que nous
prenons les quarts devraient être de 20%
ça reste considérable mais pourquoi
est-ce que cette évolution est notable
parce que d'une part le taux d'emploi et
la part de vie consacrée à l'activité
des femmes tant augmenter du fait de
l'égalité professionnelle et c'est
plutôt une très bonne nouvelle en termes
de répartition d'émancipation et de
capacité de ne pas que société à
accompagner l'emploi des femmes mais
aussi parce que ça me permet de dire que
souvent dans le débat sur les retraites
on a une tentation mais que je peux
entendre comprendre de faire du système
de retraite une espèce de grande machine
à réparer les injustices de la vie que
nous puissions récompenser c'est une
bonne chose mais dire que le système de
retraite nous permettra de réparer de
compenser ou de niveler toutes les
injustices toutes les inégalités
accumulées tout au long d'une vie me
paraît peut-être un peu éligioire ou en
tout cas trop ambitieux comme comme
dessin et enfin vous m'avez interrogé
sur un centre de régime nous maintenons
les régimes de l'Opéra et de la comédie
pour des raisons liées essentiellement à
la pratique par exemple de la danse
passer un certain âge nous maintenons
les régimes de Lénine ce qui correspond
au marin pêcheurs c'est une des
professions à la fois les plus
difficiles mais aussi les plus exposées
malheureusement au décès en activité et
vous m'avez interrogé sur la manière
dont pourrait être accompagné
ou concerner les fonctions publiques
parlementaires du Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez raison de poser la
question mais nous considérons que c'est
une décision qui relève du bureau des
assemblées et donc c'est au bureau des
assemblées concernées de prendre ses
décisions et de se prononcer
très bien merci bien monsieur le
ministre pour donc tous ces éléments de
réponse nous allons passer déjà aux
questions de députés je vous le dis tout
de suite
je vais déjà prendre les questions des
députés des personnes qui n'ont pas posé
de questions les orateurs ce sont déjà
c'est exprimés pendant 5 minutes donc on
a encore beaucoup de questions donc on
verra après le temps effectivement qui
nous restera et je tiens à dire
également et je reprécise ces deux
minutes et pas deux minutes zéro une
d'accord Monsieur Didier Le Gac pour
deux minutes
merci madame la Présidente je serai très
rapide puisque le ministre a répondu
déjà aux deux questions que je voulais
lui poser les deux points sur lequel je
voulais l'interroger ce soir d'abord sur
l'amiante nouveau président du groupe
d'études amiante de l'Assemblée
nationale je voulais interroger mais il
a répondu déjà très clairement en disant
que les dispositifs d'amiante était
maintenues dans le projet de réforme de
retrait je m'en félicite parce que déjà
la cata qui est la location anticipée
pour les travailleurs de l'amiante a été
prolongé reconduit jusqu'en 2027 c'est
une bonne nouvelle et donc le fait que
les personnes atteintes de l'amiante ne
se rend pas toucher la réforme des
retraites est aussi une bonne nouvelle
et je voulais l'interroger aussi sur le
régime de Lénine puisque député d'une
circonscription très maritime dans le
Finistère il vient d'y répondre très
clairement le régime des marins
effectivement métier le plus dangereux
au monde est exclu également de la
réforme merci
très bien
la parole est à Monsieur Victor Catteau
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre le 5 mai 2010 lors d'une
question gouvernement un député
socialiste interpellé le ministre du
Travail de l'époque au sujet de la
réforme des retraites repoussant l'âge
légal de départ de 60 à 62 ans il disait
je cite cette volonté de reculer l'âge
de la retraite et doublement injuste
d'une part les cartes d'omber la
recherche d'autres recettes d'autre part
elle fera porter les forces sur les
générations nées après 1970 aujourd'hui
plus préoccupé par leur situation
actuelle par le rentrer sur le marché du
travail que par la question de leur
retraite et ce député c'est vous
monsieur le ministre enfin c'est ce que
vous étiez car aujourd'hui dans le plus
grand des calmes vous venez nous
annoncer que vous souhaitez faire
reculer l'âge de légal de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans 64 ans mais où est
donc passé votre bon sens oui donc
passer votre humanité depuis quand
êtes-vous devenu aussi déconnecté de la
réalité comment pouvez-vous croire
Monsieur le Ministre qu'à 64 ans après
une carrière longue et de dur labeur on
ne soit pas usé par la vie un quart des
Français les plus pauvres décèdent avant
même d'atteindre les 62
et puis il n'y a pas que nos aînés qui
vont subir car si vos idées ont
soudainement changé sûrement aller chez
par l'odeur de la soupe la situation que
vous décriviez reste la même faire
reculer le déplage de départ à la
retraite c'est faire porter les forces
sur les plus jeunes générations et plus
que le doublement injuste sa réforme est
également et surtout injustifiée le
corps à travers son président qu'on a eu
la chance auditionner pas plus tard que
jeudi dernier l'affirme lui-même les
dépenses des retraites ne dérapent elles
sont relativement maîtrisées donc
contrairement à ce que vous tentez tant
bien que mal de faire croire aux
Français notre système de retraite
actuelle n'est pas en danger alors
monsieur le ministre du Travail du Pôle
emploi de l'insertion et de la classe
sociale ma question sera double quand
entendrez-vous enfin le message des
Français et quand est très vous ne
cesser de les escroquer je vous remercie
très bien la parole est à Madame Rachel
kéké pour deux minutes madame kéké merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre le 10 janvier dernier madame
bonne a déclaré nous demanderons aux
employeurs une contribution
supplémentaire pour le financement de la
retraite mais nous refusons quelle
augmentation le trou du travail c'est
pourquoi nous baisserons si mes
trucments la cotisation des employeurs
au régime des accidents du travail et
des maladies professionnelles qui est
très accidentaires alors que la France
est champion d'Europe en accident du
travail et même d'accident mortel du
travail la première ministre nous dit
que c'est dans la caisse d'accident du
travail et maladie professionnelle
qu'elle va aller chercher de l'argent
pour financer sa réforme quelle honte
vous voulez faire travailler les gens au
moins deux ans de plus pour soi-disant
sauver un système d'un retraites qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas en danger puis
pour financer cette attaque vous allez
vous servir dans la caisse des
essentiels et des nombreux victimes de
la pénibilité et des accidents du
travail qui sont aujourd'hui encore
sous-évalués il est donc plus facile
pour vous d'obliger des millions des
gens à travailler plus en prenant deux
ans de leur vie plutôt que des taxer les
employeurs ou de trouver d'autres
tous promettent en place une réforme des
retraites vraiment juste cette
déclaration supplémentaire de Madame
bonne dit bien des choses sur le mépris
profond que vous avez pour les
travailleurs et travailleurs et les
pauvres de ce pays pourtant sans le
travail de ces gens le pays ne tourne
pas merci
la parole est à Monsieur Joël merci
madame la Présidente la reporteur
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je dis dernier à l'appel des
syndicats-unis sous la même bannière
plus d'un million de citoyens
manifestaient pour défendre leur
retraite certaines notamment d'être les
travailleurs carrière longue ou ceux
souffrant de pénibilité au travail
manifester même pour conserver le droit
de partir à la retraite en bonne santé
car la réforme que vous proposez aux
Français est un recul social comme nous
avons peu connu ces dernières décennies
alors que l'argent magique a coulé à
flot pendant le conflit le covid nous
vous devons nous nous demandions tout ce
qui allait payer le quoiqu'il en coûte
désormais il n'y a plus de place au
doute plutôt que de mettre contribution
les super riches ou les multinationales
vous demandez aux Français de travailler
deux ans de plus les inégalités sont à
tous les niveaux comme tout le monde
entre l'étude d'impact une femme née
dans les années 80 devra travailler 8
mois de plus à cause de votre réforme
pour un homme de la même génération ces
quatre supplémentaires vous ne renforcez
pas que les inégalités sociales pour
renforcer une inégalité de genre déjà
criante le vernis social dont vous avez
essayé d'habiller votre réforme n'y
changera rien il ressemble plus à une
carotte pour faire passer la pilule qu'à
une vraie volonté d'améliorer notre
système de retraite comme 9 actifs sur
10 comme la majorité des Français je
suis farouchement opposé à cette réforme
des retraites ce gouvernement n'est
toujours plus créatif lorsqu'il s'agit
de vider les poches des classes moyennes
que pour établir un peu de justice
sociale alors Monsieur le Ministre
pourquoi s'obstiner a reculé l'âge
d'égal de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
alors que les Français y sont opposés
pourquoi ne pas envisager d'autres
solutions comme une augmentation de
cotisation sociale ou une serrure
imposition des plus favorisées je vous
remercie
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre exposé
vos premières réponses j'avais une
question sur l'index des seniors je suis
rassurée par la présentation du jour je
pars donc sur une question concernant
les femmes l'objectif du gouvernement et
de protéger les femmes qui ont des
carrières hachis ou incomplètes ou qui
touchent de très petites pensions ainsi
elles sont les premières bénéficiaires
de mesures incluses dans la réforme que
vous proposez comme le maintien de l'âge
de la décote à 67 ans le relèvement des
petites pensions la prise en compte des
congés parentaux pour le calcul de la
durée pour les carrières longues et pour
la proratisation du minimum de pension
et la prise en compte des trimestres
aidants comme vous l'avez dit et tout
cela essentiel mais en 2019 l'écart
entre les pensions des femmes et des
hommes aident
40,5%, en ce jour symbolique de remise
du rapport 2023 sur l'état du sexisme en
France du Haut Conseil de l'égalité
avez-vous envisagé d'autres pistes pour
réduire cet écart dans la population
générale et sinon pourriez vous pré
envisager des mesures qui pourraient
réduire cette injustice sociale dès le
moment où elle naissent c'est à dire au
premier recrutement je ne sais pas que
ma fille Imane 19 ans étudiante
subissent ce que nos aînés ont subi ou
ce que certains d'entre nous vont subir
je vous remercie très bien Monsieur
Thierry frapper 2 minutes
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre aujourd'hui dans cette
commission nombre d'entre nous
s'interrogent sur l'utilité fondamentale
d'une telle réforme et des nances en
injustice en effet vous proposez un
allongement de deux ans de l'âge légal
du départ à la retraite pour partir à
l'âge de 64 ans cette réforme est une
injustice sociale vous allez augmenter
la durée de cotisation de deux années
alors que le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités stagnent depuis 2012 vous
prenez mal en considération nos
compatriotes exerçant des métiers
contraignants difficiles mais aussi la
situation de nos seniors
ne pensez-vous pas que cette réforme va
accentuer la précarité de l'emploi chez
les seniors ne pensez-vous pas que cette
réforme va accentuer le nombre d'arrêt
maladie chez les seniors il est
important d'indiquer des gens que la
DARES a eu l'occasion d'établir un
rapport indiquant que l'employabilité
des 55 64 ans et de
56%. celle chez les 55 59 ans et de
75,1% un brancher
l'employabilité chez les 60 64 ans et de
seulement
35,5%. la précarité est donc
considérablement plus important dans la
tranche des 60 64 ans pire encore les
chiffres de la DARES démontrent que le
taux de chômage augmente au fur et à
mesure que les seniors prennent de l'âge
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple
et la suivante comment pensez-vous
permettre à nos seniors de travailler
jusque 64 ans sans difficulté dans
l'emploi je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur François Ruffin
le député prenez le début voilà
oui monsieur le ministre je suis heureux
de vous voir ici parce que vous avez
refusé un débat avec feeling Martinez
vous avez fui un débat avec Laurent
Berger vous avez refusé un BD avec
l'économiste Porcher vous refusez un
débat avec moi-même au moins on a ici on
a l'Assemblée et en dehors de cette
assemblée jeudi dernier je me trouvais
avec 2 millions de mes amis imaginaires
une aide-soignante à l'hôpital d'Amiens
qui souffre de polyarthrite et qui va
prendre deux ans de plus son mari chez
Valeo 39 ans de nuit et qui va prendre
deux ans de plus un jardinier dans les
cimetières militaires qui travaillent
dans le froid qui travaillent dans
l'humidité qui va prendre deux ans de
plus un maçon carreleur de 50 ans qui a
déjà mal au dos et qui va prendre deux
ans de plus pour eux c'est pas un truc
techno ou budgétaire c'est dans leur
chair dans leur tête et votre réforme
ils l'ont très bien compris ces deux ans
de plus vous faire de la dentelle autour
vous allez nous faire du compte de
périmidité vous allez faire de l'index
senior vous allez faire du baratin vous
n'allez vous faire du bidouillage vous
n'avez faire du brodage tout ça on
l'entend là à longueur d'heure mais
quand vous dites que 64 ans c'est
nécessaire pour le retour à l'équilibre
du système de qui quel système
parlez-vous un système injuste qui fait
que le même jour on nous a sur cette
réforme des retraites on a l'annonce du
dividende record pour les géants du CAC
40 et il y a rien dans votre loi qui
sera prévu pour aller chercher de ce
côté-là du côté de vos amis qui ne sont
pas imaginaires vos amis milliardaires
vos amis que Emmanuel Macron reçoit
l'Élysée encore vendredi dernier en les
assurant qu'il y aura rien tu es super
dividende rien sur la super profit voilà
l'équilibre la justice mais il y a pire
c'est l'équilibre démocratique quand
cette Français sur dix vous dit non
quand huit salariés sur 10 vous dire non
quand deux tiers des Français vous
disent il faut aller chercher dans les
grandes fortunés dans les grandes firmes
vous vous ne comptez pas convaincre vous
comptez seulement vaincre vaincre par la
lassitude d'un col par la résignation va
parler au début ma question mesurez-vous
le mal que vous faites à la République
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre j'ai été interpellée par un
agriculteur à la retraite depuis
plusieurs années de ma circonscription
qui a commencé à travailler à 17 ans et
qui a par ailleurs été adjoint dans sa
commune pendant 19 ans celui-ci ne
bénéficie pas d'une pension équivalente
à 85 % du SMIC pourtant voter en 2020 en
faveur des anciens chefs d'exploitation
agricoles ayant une carrière complète
puisque les anciens élus voient leur
retraite Ircantec Régime Obligatoire
d'élus prise en compte dans le calcul de
la pension de retraite cette injustice a
été partiellement réparée la loi portant
en mesure d'urgence pour la protection
du pouvoir d'achat voté en août 2022 a
permis de ne plus tenir compte des
droits en cours de constitution à
l'IRCANTEC toutefois cette disposition
ne règle pas la situation de nombreux
agriculteurs déjà retraités avant les
lois de 2020 et 2022
que répondez-vous à ces agriculteurs qui
avaient déjà donc liquidé leur retraite
qui ont cumulé pendant plusieurs années
leur activité professionnelle et un
engagement dans une collectivité
pénalisée du coup par leurs
investissement au service de nos
concitoyens merci
la parole est à Monique Ibra je vous
donne le micro prenez le pardon merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre un point sensible donne un lieu
à des questionnements et des polémiques
concerne le report de l'âge concernant
les femmes celui-ci leur serait
défavorable en tout cas plus défavorable
que le report concernant les hommes
pouvez-vous nous préciser ces éléments
merci
très bien merci pour la concision de la
question monsieur Sébastien Petavy
vous avez la parole sur le député et je
vous souhaite la bienvenue dans notre
commission merci
monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente alors vous faites notamment
le pari de l'amélioration de l'emploi
des seniors par un seul et unique outil
l'index senior alors que l'index
d'égalité professionnelle homme-femme à
briller par son île efficacité l'index
senior est une régression supplémentaire
qu'elle suffirait pour l'entreprise de
le publier pour échapper aux sanctions
qu'importe les résultats obtenus
confirmez-vous donc monsieur le ministre
que la sanction ne s'appliquerait qu'en
cas de non publication ou est-il prévu
également des sanctions de sanctionner
les entreprises présentant des résultats
insuffisants d'ailleurs actuellement
aucun barème n'est prévu c'est là où on
constate que vous n'avez pas totalement
recopié l'intégralité de l'index égalité
professionnelle qui lui avait au moins
le mérite de prévoir un score minimum à
atteindre sachant que les modalités de
définition des indicateurs sont flous
pourriez-vous nous préciser si les
entreprises auront ou non à respecter un
score minimum de la même manière que
l'index égalité professionnelle n'a
nullement prouvé son utilité à lutter
contre les inégalités au travail si
cette index senior
ni cette index seniors ni votre réforme
ne prend en compte l'emploi des seniors
alors que même de votre point de vue le
point de vue comptable rien que
l'égalité salariale ajouterait 12 % de
cotisations par an comment comptez-vous
concrètement prendre en compte l'impact
de votre réforme délétère sur la vie des
Françaises enfin pourriez-vous
considérer d'augmenter la sanction de 1%
des rémunérations pour la rendre
réellement dissuasive et ainsi d'établir
une grille de sanctions adaptée à chaque
taille d'entreprise merci
très bien je passe la parole à Nicole
dubrechirat merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre merci pour vos
propos et le travail réalisé en
concertation la retraite s'inscrit dans
le prolongement de la vie
professionnelle la vie au travail est
diverses en fonction du parcours de
chaque individu après une période
ponctuée de phase en alternance en
apprentissage souffre une période faite
d'activité dans le secteur public privé
ou libéral vous faites de parcours
mixtes une période d'activité faite
également de période de formation tout
au long de la vie la retraite vient
ensuite et elle reflète cette diversité
de parcours professionnel toute réforme
du système de retraite sans visage de
manière globale pour ce qui concerne le
volet financier Monsieur Lebrun
président du corps a souligné que
l'évolution des dépenses de retraite
reste constante mais nous devons faire
face à une diminution des recettes une
diminution liée à la démographie aux
modalités liées au parcours de fin
d'activités et dépendantes de la
conjoncture économique notamment des
taux d'emploi et de chômage cette
réforme paramétrique est financière de
par forme sous la forme d'une loi de
finance de sécurité sociale
rectificative se comprend cependant
est-il possible de prévoir d'éventuelles
leviers supplémentaire envisager
l'hypothèse d'un plancher de départ à 63
ans pour les femmes à bas revenu et avec
des carrières hachées ce qui existe dans
d'autres pays européens sur la mesure
qui permettrait une modulation d'un taux
de CSG je pense à une hausse sur les
taux de retraite les plus élevés même si
je sais qu'il n'est pas prévu
d'augmenter les impôts cependant
l'inclusion des seniors demande du temps
et dépend du taux de chômage plus ou
moins prévisible le très question était
sur les jeunes et les modalités de
rachat de trimestre et la dernière
question est sur la révision des droits
familiaux pour arriver à une équité
entre les trimestres
validés pour les enfants entre le public
et privé et ainsi que sur les pensions
de réversion comme c'était envisagée
dans le précédent très fort je vous
remercie très bien Monsieur Jérôme Guedj
la parole deux minutes
promis madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
bon le hasard fait que c'est mon
anniversaire aujourd'hui et que vous
vous offrez vous m'offrez un trimestre
de plus de cotisation et deux années de
plus personnellement je m'en fiche j'ai
très envie de pouvoir travailler le plus
longtemps possible parce que j'ai la
chance d'appartenir à des activités dans
lequel je peux m'épatouiller mesmensité
que ce soit dans la fonction publique
dans laquelle je suis mais sauf que
voyez-vous la génération 1972 à laquelle
j'appartiens à cette particularité c'est
que c'est la génération la plus
importante du baby-boom il y a eu 877
000 naissances en 1972 c'est le plus
haut du baby-boom entre 45 et 1972 et
parmi cette génération il y a des gens
comme moi qui seront très contents de
pouvoir et de vouloir travailler plus
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui mais il y
a aussi parmi eux 42% qui sont des
employés et des ouvriers dont une grande
partie d'entre eux ne trouveront pas
dans ce trimestre supplémentaire
accéléré et dans les deux années
supplémentaires la quelconque source
d'émancipation et d'épanouissement mais
au contraire
le risque aggraver de la fatigabilité de
l'épuisement des risques pour pour la
suite et donc je voulais que vous ayez
une fois de plus la mesure des
conséquences de la réforme que vous
portez ma question elle va porter sur un
autre sujet mais qui n'est pas si
éloigné parce qu'on comprend bien que
votre effort elle est motivée
essentiellement par des aspects relatifs
à l'équilibre des finances publiques il
y a un avis du haut-commité des finances
publiques qui a été du Haut Conseil
pardon qui a été joint et qui dit je
cite que compte tenu du caractère
incomplet des informations qui ont été
transmises par le gouvernement le Haut
conseil n'est pas en mesure d'évaluer
l'incidence de moyen terme de la réforme
des retraites sur les finances publiques
alors comment faites-vous d'un côté pour
nous dire que c'est une réforme qui va
permettre de rééquilibrer et que l'eau
au conseil nous dise qu'il n'est pas
capable à long terme ou à moyen terme de
l'apprécier très bien monsieur dernière
question Yannick Monet je passe la
parole à Monsieur le Ministre
merci madame la Présidente on a un point
de divergence de fond c'est à dire que
vous vous considérez que les problèmes
des retraites c'est un problème de
dépenses et donc vous faites une réforme
en expliquant qu'elle va être plus juste
en dépensant moins ça ça reste une
énigme pour moi et nous on pense que
c'est un problème de recettes puisqu'il
faut chercher de nouvelles recettes pour
avoir une retraite plus juste néanmoins
j'ai trois questions assez précises on a
reçu des documents entre midi et deux
j'aimerais savoir quelle est la nature
de ces documents parce que j'étais
surpris par le premier document ça
ressemble pas un document habituel ça
ressemblait davantage à un document
intract 212 pages certes mais un tract
et est-ce qu'on aura est-ce qu'on aura
une étude d'impact
ma deuxième question vous avez reconnu à
MIMO je l'ai en tout cas interprété
comme ça
quand vous dites que vous reconnaissez
que personne n'est surpris de cette
réforme j'ai cru comprendre que vous
reconnaissez un mot qui n'était pas très
honnête de considérer l'élection
présidentielle élection législative
comme un référendum sur les retraites
c'est d'ailleurs totalement quand on
regarde le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle et le deuxième tour des
élections d'un symptôme d'élection
législative effectivement ça ne s'est
pas joué sur ce sujet des retraites en
tout cas ce qu'il prétendent ne font pas
preuve d'une grande honnêteté mais
pourquoi ne pas passer par une par un
référendum par une consultation
populaire sur un sujet aussi important
ma dernière question c'est que j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il y avait des problèmes
techniques sur la question des 1200
euros et j'ai envie que vous nous
éclairiez sur cette question parce que
j'ai cru qu'on un article de presse qui
est sorti récemment là dans la journée
comme quoi vous aurez des difficultés à
identifier les personnes qui devraient
bénéficier des 1200 euros j'aimerais en
savoir un peu plus je vous remercie
très bien bien merci pour toutes ces
nombreuses questions et je passe la
parole à Monsieur le Ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
avant de répondre aux questions dans
l'ordre et on commence à par Monsieur
Catteau je voudrais d'abord me présenter
mes excuses à la commission puisque tout
à l'heure je n'ai pas répondu à la
question des rachats trimestres qui m'a
été posé par plusieurs intervenants et
notamment par Monsieur Maillard qui me
l'a fait justement remarquer je vais
simplement dire que sur les rachats de
trimestres nous avons deux chantiers un
premier chantier d'amélioration de
l'information qui est extrêmement
difficile à avoir et encore plus
difficile à avoir au moment où il faut
l'avoir je prends un simple exemple mais
le rachat de trimestre de stage fait
pendant des études n'est possible que
pendant deux ans après la fin du stage
et personne ne le sait et pourtant les
conditions de rachat sont très
avantageuses puisqu'on est sur quelques
centaines d'euros par trimestre
quelques centaines d'euros par trimestre
et donc nous sommes très ouverts un
travail d'amélioration de l'information
avec le groupement d'intérêt public sur
les retraites et très preneur aussi
d'avancer sur les modalités qui
permettent d'acquérir ces de racheter
pardon cette trimestre en termes de
délai je pense par exemple que dire
qu'un rachat de trimestre de stage
pourrait être soit dans les 5 ans qui
suivent la fin des études soit avant 30
ans ce serait beaucoup plus juste que de
dire que ces deux ans avant après la fin
d'un stage de la même manière que le
rachat de trimestres pourrais-tu
pourrait être conditionné dans des
paramètres un peu identiques pour être
sûr que tous ceux qui le peuvent qui le
souhaitent et qui en a possibilité par
le droit de racheter des trimestres
puissent le faire à un moment où c'est
possible et un moment où ça reste
relativement avantageux puisque plus les
trimestres sont achetés tard plus c'est
difficile pour des raisons de droit
c'est parfois interdit et surtout plus
c'est cher puisque le coût de rachat des
trimestres est basé sur une méthode dite
actuelle et donc plus le temps passe
plus cette trimestre sont chers à
racheter et donc je souhaite c'est le
cas que nos futurs débats nous
permettent d'avancer sur ces sujets là
pour répondre à Monsieur Catteau j'ai
l'occasion de revenir sur un centre de
points vous avez les mêmes références
littéraires que Monsieur Delaporte et
Monsieur Clouet donc je vous félicite
vous aussi d'aller vers les bons auteurs
mais simplement répondre à un point de
votre intervention vous dites 25% des
ouvriers 25% des classes populaires sont
décédées à 62 ans ça n'est pas ça c'est
une information qui tourne en boucle qui
a été reprise y compris d'ailleurs je
l'ai vu sur un compte Instagram ou
Twitter par la mer de Paris c'est une
fake news et je vais simplement vous
dire pourquoi mais je vais le dire en
reprenant les mots d'autres qui l'ont
fait avant moi
ça ne concerne pas le travail et la
retraite et effectivement quand on
regarde la population et qu'on l'arrange
par 100e de personnes en fonction du
revenu le ce qu'on regarde non pas les
10% les 20% les 30 % de personnes les
plus modestes mais quand on regarde les
5 % de Français les plus modestes il y a
effectivement un taux de mortalité qui
est de 25% avant 60 ans et lorsqu'on
parle des 5% de Français les plus
modestes on parle de gens qui quittent
leur vie ont eu des revenus inférieurs à
540 euros donc on est malheureusement
est-ce que c'est le signe d'une très
grande précarité non pas face à des gens
qui meurent tôt à cause du travail mais
face à des gens qui meurent tôt parce
qu'ils sont dans une grande précarité et
c'est tout aussi inadmissible mais faire
le lien comme vous l'avez repris entre
ce chiffre de 25% et la condition des
classes populaires ou des travailleurs
les plus modestes ne tient pas donc
vraiment
concentrons-nous sur la lutte contre la
grande précarité mais ne faisons pas de
ce chiffre sur 5% des Français et les
plus modestes un argument dans un débat
sur des retraites alors que ça n'a pas
de lien avec le monde du travail madame
kiki a dû nous quitter mais j'avais
répondu de toute façon sur la question
du financement
atmpé des éléments de réponse
précédemment madame
fantaberette a évoqué la question de
l'égalité professionnelle et je pense
que ça fait partie effectivement des
choses sur lesquelles nous devons
avancer de manière indépendante
finalement à la réforme des retraites
tout ce que nous pouvons faire pour
améliorer l'égalité professionnelle et
ça me permet de dire que l'index est
plus efficace que ce qui est dit parfois
index sur l'égalité professionnelle pour
une raison toute simple c'est qu'elle
n'est après année la note moyenne des
entreprises assujetti à cette obligation
de publication est une note qui est en
progression ce qui signifie que les
entreprises font des efforts pour
améliorer la prise en compte et la
réduction des inégalités
professionnelles entre les femmes et les
hommes mais c'est cette réduction des
inégalités qui permettra de réduire
l'inégalité de retraite parce que le
principal facteur d'inégalité sur le
montant des retraites entre les femmes
et les hommes tient au niveau de revenus
pendant et tient en fait que les femmes
sont plus exposées encore aujourd'hui
aucun hiérarchique que les hommes donc
c'est vraiment un chantier très
structurel de d'égalité professionnelle
qui nous permettra d'avancer nous avons
mis quelques mesures qui permettent je
crois dit participer monsieur frappé a
dit finalement non pas des seigneurs et
l'index ça ne sert à rien je ne
répondent sur l'égalité professionnelle
et ce que vous avez fait ce que vous
avez dit en terme d'inficité à vos yeux
ça marche mieux que ce que vous avez dit
par contre là où je pourrais peut-être
vous rejoindre sur un point de fond
c'est lorsque vous dites monsieur le
député que notre politique serait
inutile une efficace et elle s'arrêtait
au seul index et oui sinon nous ne
faisions que l'index ça ne serait pas
suffisant c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons d'autres dispositions dans le
texte je pense notamment aux facilités
d'accès à la retraite progressive devant
avant l'âge de départ je pense aucune
l’emploi retraite je pense à l'ouverture
de la retraite progressive au
retraités aux assurés de la fonction
publique qui n'en n'ont pas le droit
aujourd'hui je pense aussi à des mesures
que nous allons prendre en dehors du
texte notamment sur les questions de
formation
sur les questions d'articulation entre
les règles qui encadrent l'indemnisation
dont il de l'assurance chômage et
l'accès à la retraite et il y a une
pension de retraite à taux plein et donc
il n'y a pas que l'index des seniors
pour répondre l'index au Seigneur pour
répondre à la problématique de l'emploi
des seniors et ça reste quelque chose de
tout à fait considérable à régler
monsieur Ruffin vous avez
évoqué un certain nombre de choses
notamment sur des quatre types que vous
avez dit ou évoqué je ne reviens pas
dessus mais en fonction de l'âge qu'ils
ont ce n'est pas deux ans ça peut être
moins ça dépend évidemment de leur âge
et notamment je pense que dans les
quatre types que vous avez évoqué vous
avez évoqué des hommes et des femmes qui
exercent des métiers qui généralement
que généralement nous retrouvons parmi
soit les bénéficiaires de dispositifs
car Irlande soit de pénibilité mais
au-delà de cela votre intervention a
appelé l'attention de la Commission sur
une situation sur une profession
particulière donc je veux dire un mot ce
sont les aides-soignants et au-delà des
effrayants je parlais des aidants et des
infirmiers j'ai dit très rapidement dans
mon propos liminaire que nous avons
l'intention de créer un fond de
prévention de l'usure et la pénibilité à
hauteur d'un milliard d'euros pour le
régime général ce matin avec mon
collègue Stanislas greening nous avons
dit que nous créons aussi par ce texte
un fond de prévention pour la fonction
publique hospitalière et que Stanislas
Grigny et Dominique fort envers des
discussions vont ouvrir pendant des
discussions avec les employeurs
territoriaux dans le respect du principe
de l'administration pouvoir comment
créer un fond un peu analogue quand la
fonction publique territoriale pourquoi
est-ce que c'est important et pourquoi
est-ce que ça fait le lien à votre
question quand on parle d'infirmiers et
d'aide soignants pour la fonction
publique hospitalière que l'on connaît
les établissements purement hospitaliers
ça me permettait cette simplification
nous avons deux catégories et même 3
finalement nous avons les infirmiers qui
sont infirmiers depuis avant 2010 qui en
2010 ce sont lui proposer un droit
d'option
soit resté catégorie B et garder le
bénéfice d'une catégorie active avec un
départ anticipé de 5 ans soit devenir
catégoria et perdre le départ anticipé
parce que perdre la caractère actif de
la catégorie et les nouveaux et les
nouveaux infirmiers recrutés après 2010
sont tous en catégorie donc sans
catégories actives sont des parents
disciples les aides soignants dans
l'hôpital public de la SPA ont un des
parenticipés de 50 parce qu'on regarde
du côté du secteur privé il y a des
aides soignants et des infirmiers qui
sont éligibles qui ne sont pas éligibles
catégorie actifs ça n'existe pas qui
sont éligibles professionnels de
prévention c'est de ce que nous faisons
en matière d'intégration notamment
d'abaissement pardon des seuils de 120
s'ennuyer pour le travail de nuit à
l'année va permettre de rendre beaucoup
plus facilement éligible ces infirmiers
ces aides soignants du secteur privé à
des points de C2P de la même manière que
les métiers pénibles que j'ai évoqués
qui permettront des accords de
prévention des départs en situation
médicale vont aussi les concerner pour
les postures pénibles et le port de
charge parce que malheureusement tous
les hôpitaux et tous les iPads ne sont
pas équipés par des rails et si je finis
le tour d'horizon par la fonction
publique territoriale on retrouve des
infirmiers des infirmières qui sont
catégoria mais qui de toute façon n'ont
jamais eu de catégorie active parce que
fonction publique territorial et des
aides soignants qui n'ont pas le CP
parce qu'ils sont dans le secteur public
et qui ne sont pas catégoriques parce
qu'ils sont en fonction publique
territoriale et donc cette question des
aidants des infirmiers justifie à 1000%
pardon pour cette familiarité le fait de
créer un fond de prévention spécifique
pour les métiers du son parce que d'une
part sont des métiers pénible et d'autre
part la disparité des situations selon
le cadre le corps d'emploi ou le statut
public ou privé que qui concerne ce qui
exercent ce métier est tellement énorme
qu'on ne peut pas rester avec ces
injustices là alors je sais que vous ne
serez pas d'accord avec la réforme
globalement on aura le débat dans
l'hémicycle je préfère toujours le débat
parlementaire à d'autres à d'autres
enceintes mais sur ce secteur là je suis
sûr que si on avance dans ce texte ou
après avec le fond de prévention
peut-être qu'on peut trouver des points
de convergence ou de consensus sur la
manière de les accompagner et de les
aider
madame le naboura a évoqué la question
du de des élus locaux qui ont cumulé une
profession d'indépendance d'agriculteurs
avec un mandat nous avons traité comme
vous l'avez dit le flux si on reprend ce
terme je vais vérifier mais a priori au
mois de mars ce qu'on appelle une lettre
ministre en termes de couverture permet
aussi de d'appliquer les mêmes règles
stock mais c'est un point que nous avons
en tête je vérifié que l'application
soit bien complète ça nous était revenu
par ailleurs
madame Bora a évoqué la question des
femmes aujourd'hui l'âge moyen non pas
légal évidemment mais l'âge moyen
affectif de départ à la retraite des
femmes et plus bas que celui des hommes
du fait du bénéfice des majorations de
durée d'affiliation au régime les 8
trimestres liés notamment à la maternité
relever légèrement l'âge légal de départ
tant diminuer l'effet de cette
majoration en termes de capacités à
partir après l'âge légal mais plutôt que
là j'effectif des hommes les études que
l'on a montre qui a horizon 2030 là j'ai
fictif de départ à la retraite entre les
femmes et les hommes sera ce sera
rapproché mais restera deux mois
inférieures pour les femmes par rapport
aux hommes et nous prenons d'autres
dispositions qui viennent non pas
compenser mais atténuer et mettre des
éléments de justice le fait de dire que
l'éligibilité au minimum de pension
tiendra compte pour reconstituer une
carrière complète des trimestres cotisés
au titre de l'assurance vieillesse des
parents au foyer assurance vieillesse
qui est accessible aux parents qui
s'arrêtent de travailler ou qui
travaillent tant partiel dès lors qu'ils
sont bénéficiaires d'une prestation d'un
minima social relatif à la garde
d'enfants c'est une façon de protéger et
de protéger de les femmes le fait
d'intégrer dans les trimestres prises en
compte les mêmes trimestres pour l'accès
à des parents de CP pour carrière longue
c'est aussi une amélioration de
situations je m'en explique d'un mot sur
cet aspect là mais aujourd'hui vous avez
des femmes qui commencent à travailler
avant 18 ans avant 20 ans qui arrive à
60 ans qui demande à bénéficier d'un
départ anticipé parce que elle considère
qu'elles ont acquis les 42 unités
nécessaires sauf que les trimestres
cotisés au titre de la VPF la VPF ne
sont pas considérés comme à qui dans ce
cadre là et donc parce qu'elles se sont
arrêtées de travailler pour une raison
évidente qui consiste à s'occuper d'un
enfant nouvellement né nouveau né elle
perd le bénéfice du départ anticipé
enfin il a un certain nombre de choses
que nous faisons avec la réforme qui
permettent notamment dans ces effets
redistributifs d'être beaucoup plus
favorables aux femmes aux hommes je l'ai
évoqué notamment sur le rendement en
termes de niveau de pension pour les les
femmes et les hommes et je les dis que
tout à l'heure à monsieur de Courson
mais progressivement les quarts moyens
de retraite de pension de retraite entre
les femmes et les hommes tant à baisser
tant mieux et tout ce qu'on peut faire
pour l'accélérer notamment par l'égalité
professionnelle et une bonne chose pour
l'intervention de Monsieur Petavy je ne
reviens pas sur ce que j'ai dit à
Monsieur frappé pardon concernant
d'autres mesures que le seul index je
vous confirme si le député que
l'obligation de publicité sera faite aux
entreprises depuis 300 salariés et que
cette obligation de publicité si elle
n'est pas respectée sera sanctionnée
d'une sanction financière pour aller
jusqu'à 1% de la masse salariale par
majoration des cotisations versées par
l'entreprise
des échanges que nous avons eu avec ce
des partenaires sociaux je précise
volontairement ça qui ont trouvé le
principe de l'index intéressant nous ont
amené à constater que côté entreprise ou
en tout cas organisation d'employeur
comme côté organisation syndicale
l'obligation de négociation sur l'emploi
des seniors par être un levier d'action
suffisant est-ce que le temps nous
montrera que c'est suffisant ou pas il
faut laisser peut-être un petit peu de
temps à cela avant d'envisager un autre
niveau coercitif par contre ça ne
marchera mais là je ne le refais pas et
je ne le redis pas que si nous avons la
possibilité de pousser d'autres mesures
que j'ai déjà évoqué pour la question de
l'emploi des seniors et je vous répète à
vous aussi pardon que en matière
d'égalité professionnelle c'est plutôt
encourageant les questions de Madame
dubreeshira sur le rachat de trimestre
et la révision des droits familiaux j'y
ai répondu il y a un instant sur la
question de l'augmentation qui parfois
proposée par certains du taux de CSG sur
les retraités de la mise à contribution
des retraités actuels vous savez madame
la députée ce n'est pas notre volonté
dans une période où on est dans une
logique de
pour les questions relatives à Monsieur
Guedj d'abord une remarque monsieur le
député je savais que c'était votre
anniversaire mais si j'avais commencé
par ça vous m'auriez accusé de vouloir
vous séduire ou d'atténuer le débat donc
bon anniversaire maintenant que c'est
dit et que j'ai pu être désagréable
avant de vous souhaiter un bon
anniversaire ce que vous avez posé comme
question sur la génération 1972 renvoie
à mon sens plus à une difficulté que
nous avons collectivement dans le
rapport au travail qu'on peut entretenir
plus que finalement la question des
seules retraites et je pense que ça m'a
bien au-delà on a pu ouvrir les assises
du travail récemment avec bon nombre de
partenaires sociaux d'intellectuels de
personnalité qualifiées et je souhaite
vraiment que nous puissions repenser
cette question du rapport au travail et
je distingue très volontiers dans mes
propos comme dans la manière dont
j'essaye de travailler la question de
l'emploi du travail je connais des tas
de gens qui sont très attachés à leur
emploi mais qui n'aiment pas leur
travail et peut-être que le fait d'être
Rachel d'être attaché un emploi qui
garantit un moyen de subsistance mais de
ne pas aimer un travail et parfois une
explication aux inquiétudes ou à
l'angoisse que suscite la perspective de
travailler un peu plus longtemps à
l'échelle d'une vie mais on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir sur le Conseil
des finances publiques je crois que la
vie que vous avez cité renvoie à la
conséquence qualifierait de tout a pu
mais les documents que nous avons
transmis à l'issue du conseil des
ministres notamment sur les trajectoires
financières montrent que l'on s'est bien
documenté la question du retour à
l'équilibre à horizon 2030 je sais
qu'ils ont été transmis entre le Conseil
et maintenant on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir une fois que tout le monde aura
pu en prendre en prendre connaissance je
termine par deux réponses à trois
réponses pardon à Monsieur Monet d'abord
pour vous dire Monsieur le Député que
nous n'allons pas dépenser moins dans le
même plutôt dépensé plus mais par contre
nous pouvons financer des mesures
nouvelles parce que nous aurons des
recettes supplémentaires et c'est là
tout l'enjeu de l'intérêt que nous
portons au niveau du solde sur la
question de l'application de la retraite
minimum au
retraités actuel et au retraités futures
et les difficultés techniques
éventuelles pour les retraités futures
il y en a pas il y en a pas c'est du
système d'information de façon par une
augmentation de 100 euros de minimum
contributifs à hauteur de 100 pour une
myco majoré et sans pour le myco de base
pour les retraités actuels il peut y
avoir des difficultés techniques
notamment parce que dans certaines
caisses dans certains régimes les
dossiers déposés avant 2010 n'ont pas
été numérisés parce que nous avons des
régimes très particuliers qui jusqu'à
une date très simple parfois pouvait
s'appuyer sur d'autres éléments que le
revenu comme base de cotisation c'est le
débat que nous avions eu à l'occasion de
la proposition loi de Monsieur Dib sur
les retraites agricoles nous travaillons
actuellement sur le travail purement
technique avec notamment la Caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse pour
faire en sorte que les versements
puissent intervenir dès 2023 et quitte à
le faire avec une principe de
régularisation rétroactif mais nous
avons bien conscience de certaines de
ces difficultés et nous essayons de les
résoudre enfin vous avez terminé par une
question sur la nature des documents et
ça tombe bien puisque c'est par là que
je voulais en finir moi aussi
nous vous proposons d'examiner un projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificatif parce que les
mesures que nous vous présentons pour
l'essentiel d'entre elles l'immense
majorité d'entre elles en soi un impact
sur les recettes soit sur les dépenses
de la sécurité sociale dès 2023 il y a
un caractéristique au projet de loi de
finance qui soit de l'État ou de la
sécurité sociale c'est qu'ils ne sont
pas accompagnés d'études d'impact nous
avons cependant produit un rapport sur
les conséquences et les impacts des
mesures que nous vous proposons c'est ce
document que vous avez reçu et il est
long c'est vrai puisqu'il fait 114 115
pages mais je suis assez convaincu que
vous trouverez dedans une mine
d'informations très objectivée très bien
documentée dans la semaine et il m'est
indiqué que ça déjà été fait auprès par
le Secrétariat général du gouvernement
auprès de l'Assemblée nationale vous
sera transmis évidemment la vie du
Conseil finance publique mais aussi les
fiches d'impact mesurent par mesure et
articles par article pour permettre
d'avoir le débat le plus éclairé
possible mais pour être tout à fait
précis il n'y a pas d'étude d'impact à
proprement parler la procédure ne
prévoit pas nous avons nous avons commis
ce rapport d'évaluation des conséquences
et des impacts avec la même méthodologie
pour nourrir le débat et partager le
maximum de chiffres les plus documentés
possibles
très bien merci monsieur le ministre
pour cette présentation également pour
la clarté et la précision de vos
réponses mes chers collègues on se
retrouve demain après les questions
gouvernement pour examiner les
amendements au projet de loi portant
diverses dispositions d'adaptation au
droit de l'Union européenne dans les
domaines de l'économie de la santé du
travail des transports de l'agriculture
mais par contre je vous retrouve avant
bien sûr en application de l'article 88
pour examiner justement les amendements
à 14h45 donc n'oubliez pas dans le cadre
de l'article 88 en attendant je vous
souhaite une belle soirée et je remercie
encore une fois monsieur le ministre